Die zwei Sprechstunden.
6 7 8 5 4 3 2 1.
Wie ist gerade im IRC Chat zur Sendung, hieß? Schon wieder ein Monat rum. Wenn diese Zahlen er tönen, wisst ihr, es ist Donnerstag, es ist der letzte Donnerstag im Monat und es ist Chaos Radio. Der Blue Moon, wo der Chaos Computer Club hier das Studio übernimmt und uns Dinge erzählt aus der Welt, die mit diesem komischen Strom und meistens auch dem seltsamen Internet, von dem wir alle reden, funktionieren. Heute soll es um moderne Maschinenmenschen gehen, beziehungsweise um die digitale Erweiterung analoger Zellhaufen. Und was das genau sein soll und was sich dahinter verbirgt, verraten uns natürlich heute die Gäste, die hier im Studio sind. Da sind zum einen der Herr Erdgeist. Und der Herr Steini.
Ja, auch mal wieder bei, nach all den Jahren.
Nach all den Jahren und der Herr Frank.
Guten Tag.
Guten Tag. Maschinenmenschen, was genau soll das sein und warum machen wir das heute hier? Ist das jetzt eher so das Thema liegt in der Luft und wir wollen mal drüber reden oder gibt es gerade einen brandaktuellen Anlass, weil irgendeiner von euch ein künstliches Bein hat?
Es ist bei den Nerds eigentlich schon seit Jahren ein Traum, sich da selber zu besser zu machen, sich da selber Sinne noch dazu zu tun, die man von der Natur nicht mitbekommen hat. Und gerade in letzter Zeit sind so viele spannende Erfindungen passiert, die schon die Science-Fiction-Filme fast übertreffen, die man noch vor 20 Jahren geguckt hat. Da lag das Thema einfach in der Luft und wir wollten einfach mal darüber plaudern und vor allem die Zuhörer fragen, ob die vielleicht noch spannenden Input dazu haben.
Das Tolle daran, an diesem Thema ist, dass sich da auch so trefflich in die Zukunft die Steinchen werfen lassen, um mal zu überlegen, was wird da eigentlich auf uns zukommen und welche abgefahrenen Konstrukte werden uns in den nächsten 10, 15, 20 Jahren wohl ereilen? Welche Body Enhancements kriegen wir? Und muss man die dann haben? Und wie geht man damit um, wenn sowas einen Bug hat und so weiter? Darüber wollen wir heute auch mal reden.
Ja, also einer der Antriebe dabei ist, dass die Technologie mittlerweile so weit ist, dass in vielen Stellen noch der Mangel an Ideen, die bremsen, ist aber nicht mehr die Technik selber. Und deswegen wollen wir da auch gerne mal ein bisschen drüber reden und auch mal ein bisschen erfahren, wo denn so Empfindlichkeiten sind und was unsere Hörer gerne so hätten. Weil einiges von dem, worüber wir heute reden, kann man auch einfach selber bauen.
Okay, also es geht darum, wie man den menschlichen Körper durch Technik erweitern, verbessern, vielleicht sogar ersetzen kann. Und ihr seid wie gesagt heute auch aufgerufen, anzurufen und mal zu erzählen, was würdet ihr euch gerne einbauen? Also wo denkt ihr, welche Technik würde ich jetzt gerne noch mal haben, die irgendwie meinen Körper besser macht? Oder wo wir sagen, okay, das will ich eigentlich nicht haben. Wenn sowas tatsächlich auf den Markt kommen sollte, würde ich mir einen weiten Bogen drum machen. Jetzt alle rufen. 0331 70 97 110 Jetzt gibt es ja bei technischen Entwicklungen immer diese verschiedenen Phasen. Also Sachen, die wir alle schon haben. Sachen, die in Science-Fiction-Filmen vorkommen und dazwischen so dieses graue Randgebiet. Dinge, an denen schon entwickelt wird, die man aber in der großen Öffentlichkeit nicht so hinbekommt. Da würde ich jetzt gerne mal ein paar Felder bei euch abfragen und hören, wie weit das ist und ob ich das möglicherweise dann irgendwie nächsten Donnerstag schon irgendwo im Supermarkt kaufen kann. Das Erste, was mir einfällt, weil es tatsächlich da schon am ehesten Dinge gibt, die mich an der Cybox erinnern, sind Hörgeräte.
Hörgeräte sind ungefähr die körperliche Erweiterung nach Zahnimplantaten, die die allermeisten Leute im Einsatz haben, also wo die größten Stückzahlen im Feld unterwegs sind. Da gibt es auch schon eine sehr lange Entwicklung. Eigentlich seit Elektronik miniaturisierbar war, gab es externe Hörgeräte, die immer weiter in den Körper reinwanderten oder zum Teil zumindest in den Körper reinwanderten. Da sind wir mittlerweile an einem Punkt angelangt, wo es anfängt schon ziemlich sci-fi zu sein, also wo halt digitale Signalverarbeitung soweit ist, dass man seinen Hören verbessern kann, also dass man halt besser hören kann als ein normaler Mensch, wenn man es entsprechend einstellt, dass man speichern kann, dass man Playback haben kann. Solche Sachen kommen jetzt gerade so aus dem Labor raus. Also da geht es halt rasch voran und es ist auch ein großer Markt da, der auch sehr willig und bereit ist, irgendwie es aufzunehmen und es halt auch total normal geworden ist. Wenn man es schlecht hört, kriegt man sich halt ein Hörgerät, ja, externes oder Implantat.
Aber ich finde...
Aber man hat vor allem Geld. Man sind ältere Leute, die...
Eben, deswegen der Markt ist groß. Also so eine Hersteller von Hörgeräten kann halt durchaus auch mal eine Menge Geld in Research and Development verprüfern, weil er halt eben weiß, es kriegt halt auch wieder rein.
Wobei interessanter Punkt genau da entsteht, wo es nicht darum geht, ein Handicap wieder auszugleichen, um vielleicht annähernd wieder so gut zu sein, wie man mal gewesen ist, sondern dass wir mit solchen Instrumenten heute einen Bereich tangieren, inzwischen, wo man sich auch als Normalsterblicher, der eigentlich normal gut hört, überlegt, ob man sowas nicht auch haben will, weil man mit so einem Ding möglicherweise im Vorteil ist. Weil man also einfach auf die letzten 5 Minuten noch mal schnell anhören kann, weil das Ding, die sowieso aufgenommen haben, was hat der jetzt wirklich gesagt, und das auch nochmal mit anderen Audio-Settings, weil man irgendwas dahinten, was der geflüstert hat, nicht so genau verstanden hat.
Ist das, was du da jetzt gerade erzählst, ist das schon sozusagen marktreif?
Ja, das ist State of the Art.
Also kannst du noch nicht kaufen. Playback ist noch nicht, zumindest soweit ich weiß, noch nicht im Freien Handel.
Aber es ist State of the Art. Also das ist das, was man heute machen kann.
Das kann man machen, aber es gibt es noch nicht. Wie ist es denn mit dem, also sind die dann schon nicht mehr sichtbar, also im Körper komplett integriert?
Das will man aber eigentlich auch gar nicht. Also es gibt irgendwie zwei Gründe. Der eine ist, dass überhaupt viele Leute sich mit Implantaten noch nicht so richtig wohlfühlen. Da wird in den Kopf irgendwas reingebohrt und wenn du taub bist, dann bleibt dir vielleicht nichts anderes übrig, als an den Hörnerv anzukoppeln. Aber ansonsten willst du ja nicht Version 1 oder 0.9 installieren, wenn da in zwei Jahren Version 1.0 rauskommt oder wie noch was viel Tolleres, dann müssen sie nochmal mit dem Bohrer wieder ran. Und so richtig eingebauten Implantate sind dann nicht so...
Okay, also ich würde sagen, über die Upgrade-Fähigkeit von Implantaten reden wir später nochmal. Ich halte aber fest, derzeit ist es so, Hörgeräte werden noch ins Ohr eingesetzt und funktionieren quasi ohne direkten Anschluss an den Nerven, gibt es aber auch schon...
Genau, es gibt halt Implantate, die wirklich implantiert werden, sehr direkt rangehen an die Mechanik und Elektrik. Oder die Nerven des Ohres. Und solche, die halt einfach nur schallverstärkend sind, also ein schwächeres Sinnesorgan aufwerten, dadurch, dass sie nochmal nachverstärken.
Oder über Körperschall auf den Knochen gepflanzt werden und dann über Vibrationen des Knochens ein Signal übermitteln.
Das ist ein anderes Thema, was wir auch noch besprechen müssen. Ausführlich ist dieses, wie ist die Schnittstelle zwischen Mensch und Maschine. Jetzt haben wir das mit dem Ohr. Das zweite ist ja sozusagen, was immer im science-scientischen Film vorkommt, das geht Augen. Was relativ häufig durch die Medien auch mal geht, ist so, da hat jetzt irgendjemand was eingebaut, wo er Schatten sehen kann. Wie weit sind wir denn vom echten künstlichen Auge noch entfernt?
Also momentan sind so die besten Implantate, die im Labor verbaut werden, haben sowas wie 150 bis 300 Pixel. Also jetzt nicht 150 mal 150 Pixel, sondern so 150 Pixel insgesamt. Das heißt also, da kann man so grobe Schämen, Schatten und so erkennen.
Also einen großen, großgeschriebenen Buchstaben auf Verzeitung kann man erkennen. Davon hört ihr.
Also 150 Pixel ist, kann man sich vorstellen, so ein daumengroßes Bild auf eurem Bildschirm.
Also man kann so einen Fond erkennen. Also einen Buchstaben als Buchstaben erkennen, wenn er bildfüllend vorhanden ist.
Aber dabei geht es größtenteils darum, die erst mal wieder Kontrastinformationen aus deiner Umgebung wieder zu vermitteln, dass du grob weißt, da ist die Tür, da ist noch die Wand und nicht direkt dann gegen die.
Genau, aber kurz mal um das anzumerken, das ist trotzdem bahnbrechend, weil dieser Microchip, das ist ja ein Microchip, der mit ein bisschen so ähnlich funktioniert wie eben deine Netzhaut und der bastelt jetzt auf geschickte Art und Weise Signale an deinen Sehnerv ran. Also da wird schon genau diese Maschinen-Mensch-Schnittstelle auf biologischem Wege an die Nerven direkt anzudocken. Und wir erinnern uns, der Sehnerv ist ein Teil des Gehirns. Das Auge hat sich ja aus dem Gehirn heraus entwickelt. Das heißt, da wird tatsächlich ein Stück Chip direkt an deinen Braincomputer angedockt. Also an deinen Gehirn angedockt über die Nervenbahn und vermittelt dir optische Reize. Man muss sich das vorstellen für jemanden, der tatsächlich sein Leben lang blind war, der jetzt plötzlich neue Reize erfährt und damit lernen kann und muss und darf umzugehen, um eben ein weiteres Sinnesorgan zu haben. Und das macht solche Body Enhancements ja auch so spannend, weil jeder normalsterbliche Mensch, der eigentlich gesund ist, kann seine Sinnesorgane erweitern. Es gibt ein Beispiel, kann man an der Stelle erwähnen, eine Frau hat sich einen kleinen Magneten in den Zeigeflinger implantieren lassen. Der ist mini-klein, aber wir alle wissen, die Finger sind sehr empfindlich, sehr taktil. Man kann also sehr feine Sachen fühlen. Damit konnte sie mit diesem kleinen Magneten im Finger an der Wand lang streichen und spüren, wo sich hinter der Wand eine elektrische Leitung befindet. Oder ob hier Strom drauf ist, oder ob hier an diesem Kabel ein Signal tatsächlich entlanggeht. Das konnte die im Finger spüren. Die hat also ein weiteres Sinnesorgan, sich dadurch implantieren lassen, indem sie jetzt also elektromagnetische Schwingungen als Empfindung spüren konnte.
Okay, würde ich auch auf die Liste schreiben. Und später dazu kommen Dinge, die wir eigentlich noch gar nicht können, die dann aber sozusagen technisch erweitert werden. Noch mal zurück zum Auge. Dieses 10 mal 15 Pixel ist ja wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr klein, wenn man sozusagen anguckt, was Handykameras heute schon kennen. Die Hauptschwierigkeit liegt tatsächlich auch hier wieder in der Übersetzung zwischen Maschine und Mensch, nehme ich an. So, das haben wir, also hören und sehen sind sozusagen die zwei großen Sinne. Riechen und schmecken stelle ich mir schwieriger vor, könnte ich mich vorstellen. Gibt es da auch schon was?
Also es wird nicht besonders viel daran geforscht, aber bei schmecken ist wiederum auch interessant. Eines der Dinge, die man tut, wenn der Sehnerv zum Beispiel nicht mehr da ist, dann benutzt man die Zungennerven. Also es gibt einen Prototypen, da bekommst du auf dem Zungenhintergrund so einen Chip draufgeklebt und der mit elektrischen Impulsen Zungennerven stimuliert. Und das Gehirn ist mit ein bisschen Training in der Lage, die Informationen, die auf der Zunge gebrützelt werden, in optische Informationen umzusetzen.
Die sehen dann ein Bild. Und das ist aber schon mit so 150x150 Pixeln.
Also da geht halt schon mehr so.
Okay, spannend. Aber diese anderen Sinne fallen erstmal raus. Dann haben wir noch den letzten Sinn, Tasten. Tasten vermitteln. Jetzt haben wir gerade schon gehört, wenn ich mit dem Magnet unter die Hauptpflanze kann ich Elektrofelder tasten. Was ist denn mit dem Normalen? Also sozusagen Druck vermitteln?
Es gibt da durchaus ein paar Entwicklungen, wo man versucht Nervenbahnen umzulegen. Also wenn zum Beispiel Gliedmaßen fehlen, dass man die Nervenansätze umverkabelt oder auch interfacet, um zum Beispiel bei Handprothesen einen Tasten wieder hinzubekommen. Das ist aber sehr schwierig. Das ist eine ziemlich komplexe Angelegenheit, wo momentan noch nicht so viel Fortschritt passiert. Also Hintergrund ist natürlich der, dass du, wenn du greifen willst, also mit einer Handprothese greifen willst, brauchst du irgendein Feedback, damit du präzise greifen kannst. Und dieses Feedback wieder herzustellen, da gibt es tatsächlich Entwicklungen und wird auch dann gearbeitet, also mit künstlichen Sensorfeldern, die tastempfindlich sind und Druck und unterschiedliche Stromstärken umsetzen, die dann wiederum auf unterschiedliche Nervenimpulsionen...
Ja, die projizieren das dann auf den Oberarm an bestimmte Stellen an deinem Oberarm, der ja auch empfindlich ist. Nicht so empfindlich wie dein Finger quasi, aber trotzdem wird dort eben elektrisch quasi ein Signal, also ein Druck am Oberarm projiziert, wenn man mit dem Finger was berührt und je stärker man drückt und je stärker das berührt, umso stärker wird die Empfindung am Oberarm. Und das Gehirn muss das jetzt übersetzen, umdenken in das ist jetzt das, was mein Finger spürt. Und Leute, die das machen, weil sie das machen müssen, die lernen tatsächlich, so sagen sie zumindest, wir können das ja mal glauben, dass es für sie irgendwann tatsächlich so anfühlt, als hätten sie mit dem Finger was berührt.
Okay, also muss man neu lernen, das fühlen, aber es funktioniert. Dann sind wir gleich beim nächsten, also Körperteile ersetzen, also Gliedmaßen, Hände, Arme, Beine.
Ja, wie Luke Skywalker.
Genau. Wie weit sind wir da?
Na, so historisch, so wie ein Holzbein. Ranschrauben ging immer.
Okay, also jetzt mit inklusive bewegen.
Also wir sind jetzt an dem Punkt, wo ein 100-Meter-Läufer mit Prothesen schneller ist als ein menschlicher 100-Meter-Läufer.
Aber was man ja manchmal sieht bei so Sportvideos Paralympics ist, dass das dann sozusagen mechanische Dinge sind. Also so federartig Dinge, die man sich quasi an die Restgliedmaßen anschnallt.
Das ist genau, das ist noch nicht digital, das ist nicht elektronisch, sondern einfach besser als die Sehnen, die du normalerweise im Bein verbaut hast.
Wobei man dazu sagen muss, dass die Entwicklung von diesem Zeug ist ohne Computer halt nicht möglich. Weil was sie da tun, ist ja, denn die Bewegungsabläufe simulieren im Computer. Und entsprechend halt, gerade zum Beispiel diese Federn, die bei den Läufern zum Beispiel verbaut werden, die sind ja optimiert und angepasst auf den Bewegungsablauf des Menschen. Das heißt, die sind auch sehr individuell zusammen laminiert unter Computerkontrolle.
Also pro individuum und nicht noch sozusagen pro entworfen.
Das heißt, wir sehen halt auch da, dass die mittlerweile reichlich verfügbare Rechentechnik und Computerleistung dazu beiträgt und die Möglichkeit, dass man halt auch Bewegungsabläufe tausendfach immer wiederholt samplen kann und gucken kann, wie bewegt sich jemand, also wie funktioniert so ein Bewegungsablauf tatsächlich, welche Muskel werden wann angespannt und daraus dann eben eine verbesserte Simulation zu machen, die man wiederum in Mechanik gießen kann. Ja, da gibt es halt schon doch ziemlich großen Fortschritts. Naja, Hüftgelenke zum Beispiel. Das sind halt auch so Prothesen, die millionenfach verbaut werden weltweit. Kniegelenke ist man noch nicht ganz so weit. So ein Knie ist auch mechanisch etwas kompliziert.
Das ist aber alles noch mechanisch.
Genau, wie ist es denn zu sagen mit der Luke Skywalker Hand?
Mit der Luke Skywalker Hand sieht es jetzt so aus, dass der Irakkrieg einen großen Schub dafür bedeutet hat, dass das US-amerikanische Militär ihren Veteranen da mal die Prothesen Deluxe da ran schrauben möchte und die auch gerne und bereitwillig dafür zur Verfügung stehen. Und da sind Leute mit komplett ohne Arme aus dem Krieg zurückgekommen. Den wurden Prothesen angepasst, die schon sich komplett von den Armstümpfen jetzt bewegen lassen. Und wie Steiner schon andeutete, auch taktiles Feedback erlauben für die Stümpfe.
Also eine Tasse hochnehmen, einen Schluck draus trinken, die Tasse wieder hinstellen und auch spüren, dass man sie angefasst hatte. Das ist, würde ich sagen, heute das, was man tatsächlich kaufen kann. Das ist teuer, da brauchst du jemanden, der das bezahlen kann und will. Ich glaube, das gibt es so noch nicht auf Krankenschein in Deutschland, aber da mag uns jemand belehren, wenn er das besser weiß. Aber technisch kann man das heute machen.
Also wir reden ja auch wirklich von etwas, das dann aussieht wie ein Arm.
Ja, also ich hab, der Arm ist ab der Schulter weg und dann wird an die Schulter was angeschnellt. Ich hab das gesehen, das hat so ein Gestell, das sitzt so ein bisschen fast auf beiden Schultern, ist auf der anderen Seite sozusagen gegengehalten und da ist ein kompletter Roboterarm dran, sagen wir mal. Und der wird über Nervenenden in der Schulter komplett gesteuert, sodass man damit jetzt was in die Hand nehmen kann mit eben dem Zangengriff vorne fünf Finger, die fünf Finger einzeln jetzt so zu bewegen, dass man dann mit Klavier spielt. Das ist jetzt erst am Kommen. Das dauert wohl noch ein bisschen. Aber jetzt was hochnehmen, was in die Hand nehmen.
Nur zum Verständnis sagen, es ist nicht so, dass der dann eine Färbedienung hat, wo er sagt, er greift zu. Nein, nein.
Der denkt, er will das anfassen. Das muss er natürlich auch trainieren, weil das mitunter nicht die gleichen... Man kann so schlecht rausfinden, welche Nerven wofür waren. Das probieren die da natürlich, das möglichst zu adaptieren. Aber normalerweise haut das nicht hin. Vielleicht hört jemand zu, der so ein Ding hat oder kennt oder Erfahrungen damit gesammelt hat. Es wäre wunderbar, da mehr darüber zu erfahren.
0331-70-97-110 wäre die Nummer dafür. Jetzt haben wir Tastsinne und Gliedmaßen, innere Organe. Wie ist es damit?
Herdschrittmacher, ne?
Herdschrittmacher. Iron Man ist quasi der kleine atomere Aktor. Wie ist es mit dem Verdauungssystem generell?
Alles noch ein bisschen schwierig. Wir sind, denke ich, eine einstellige Anzahl von Jahren davon entfernt, dass man innere Organe drucken kann. Also dass aus Zellen von Organen, die da sind, dass die zurückdifferenziert werden können und man auf gedruckte Gerüste wieder neue Organe wachsen lassen kann. Dass man diese Zellen sozusagen aufträgt mit so einer Art 3D-Printer in was, was in der Nährlösung zu einem Ersatzorgan ranwächst. Solange noch gesunde, eigene Zellen da sind, aus denen man diese zurückdifferenzierten Zellen machen kann, das sieht relativ gut aus. Also da kann man schon davon ausgehen, dass es so in den nächsten zehn Jahren durchaus möglich sein wird.
Das heißt sozusagen, ich gehe bei Organen, ist der Weg, den man geht eher der, dass man sagt, wir setzen das nicht künstlich, sondern wir züchten das neu.
Präzise.
Warum macht man das bei Augen zum Beispiel nicht?
Kriegt Stammzellen nicht so angeregt, dass sie ausdifferenziert werden zu Augen? Das ist ein ziemlich komplexer Wachstumsprozess.
Also noch nicht.
Ja, ich glaube auch, das kann machbar sein. Der Körper hat es geschafft, so ein Auge herzustellen. Aber wie gesagt, ein Teil des Gehirns ist womöglich komplett.
Aber eins der spannenden Dinge, die da passieren, die schon funktionieren, ist das Wachsenlassen von Haut aus den Zellen. Und was ich mich ja immer frage, warum man nicht einfach schon viel früher anfängt, so Dinge beiseite zu legen. Also sich jetzt schon Material irgendwo hinzuspenden und das einfach so in eine Petriche Halle machen zu lassen.
Üblicherweise wird die Nabelschnur, also das kann man heute haben wollen, die Nabelschnur bei der Geburt, kann man einfrieren lassen, weil da sind ohne Ende Stammzellen drin, die später, wenn das Kind mal an irgendwas garstigem Erkrankt, verwendet werden können.
Ich will aber eigentlich schon, dass mir da irgendwo in einer Petriche Halle ein Knochen wächst, den ich dann später, wenn es mir bricht oder so kaputt geht, dass es gar nicht mehr geht, dass mir den einfach nur verpflanzt werden kann. Ich will einmal einen Ersatzteillager, ja.
Ich würde aber sagen, dazu machen wir einen extra Chaosradio, zum biologischen Ersatzteillager. Heute soll es ja um die digitale Technik gehen, die man sich da einmauern kann, um die Elektronik.
Bei Augen, wo wir gerade da waren, ist es ja so, dass mit Elektrooptik sind wir ja mittlerweile ziemlich weit. Wir können ja in der mechanischen Größenordnung eines Auges sind wir mittlerweile knapp in der Lage, ungefähr die selbe Auflösung abzubilden. Von dem, was wir so sehen können.
Kann man das eigentlich beziffern? Welche Auflösung hat ein Auge?
Ein Auge hat keine statische Auflösung im Sinne einer Digitalkamera, sondern hat ja eine adaptive Auflösung. Die ist halt irgendwo in der Größenordnung von 40 Megapixel. Okay, das ist machbar. Also die du halt fokussierst auf einen Flag. Du hast ja sozusagen nicht dein gesamtes Sehfeld, sondern du hast ja immer ein kleines Sehfeld, und in dem hast du ungefähr 40 Megapixel.
Und am Rand hast du dann auch noch unterschiedliche Arten von Rezeptoren. Das heißt, wie du siehst RGB und dann auch noch die Helligkeit.
Und am Rand siehst du die Bewegung. Im Zentrum siehst du Farbe und hauptsächlich Helligkeit. Am Rand siehst du eigentlich fast schon nur noch Schwarz-Weiß oder so ein bisschen Farbe. Und dafür aber ganz stark Bewegung. Das war früher wichtig, wenn der Tiger sich von der Seite ran schleicht.
Das rechnet einem das Auge aber auch schon voraus. Das Auge ist wie gesagt eine Ausstülpung des Gehirns, und da ist schon mal krasses Präprozess mit drin. Wenn du irgendwo einen Ball fliegen siehst, dann sagt dir das Auge dem Gehirn schon, wo der Ball demnächst sein wird, weil er das ausrechnet. Deswegen funktionieren auch so Zaubertricks, wo du jemanden irgendwas hinwirfst, aber nur so tust und den Ball in der Hand behältst. Das Auge sieht einfach schon für dich im Vorfeld, dass der Ball da jetzt fliegen wird, und deswegen geht das einfach auch immer wieder. Und auf einmal ist er weg.
Okay, dann ist noch eine Stelle, die ausgelassen ist, wenn wir für klassische Sätze sprechen, und das wäre das Gehirn. Und da haben wir auch schon den ersten Anrufer, ich vermute zumindest, es hat was damit zu tun. Robin19 aus der Schweiz. Hallo und guten Abend.
Ja, hallo, guten Abend.
Du würdest über etwas erzählen, das BrainPort heißt.
Genau, richtig. Das ist ein Projekt, gibt es jetzt schon seit ein paar Jahren. Ich hab's auch mal einfach so ein paar Mal am Rande davon gehört, weil es auch mal im Fernsehen war und sich das ganz interessant angehört hat. Und zwar ist das von Forschern entwickelt worden aus Amerika. Und die haben etwas entwickelt, das besteht aus einer Brille. Da sind wohl mehrere Kameras drin verbaut, die einfach wirklich auch anscheinend funktionieren wie normale Videokameras. Die fangen eben das ein, was der Träger eben halt normalerweise in seinem Sichtfeld hätte und geben das dann weiter an einen Chip. Also das sieht irgendwie so ein bisschen aus wie so ein Traubenzuckerlutscher von der Form her, den man sich auf die Zunge legt. Und dieser Chip gibt es dann wohl über die Zunge weiter an die Nerven, auch entsprechend an die, ich weiß nicht, ob das über die Sehnerven geht oder irgendwie über ein entsprechendes Zentrum im Gehirn.
Das sind schon die Nerven in der Zunge, da hatten wir aber vorhin schon drüber berichtet. Die Dichte der Nervenzellen in der Zunge ist nämlich eine der höchsten im gesamten Körper. Deswegen funktioniert das, so ganz gute Elektroden darauf zu tun.
Ja, aber ich hatte nämlich vorhin schon angerufen, gerade als das Thema angesprochen wurde und da ich dann den Stream kurz etwas leiser machen musste, habe ich...
Okay, ja das brauchen wir auch noch sozusagen. Ohren, die gleich mehrere Audiokanäle verarbeiten können und so einen kleinen internen Mixer. Aber Robin, wo du gerade schon mal dran bist, sag mal, wenn du die Wahl hättest. Also jetzt wirklich wünscht dir was, wir nehmen jetzt mal die technische Bedenken, lassen wir erstmal außer Acht. Was würdest du dir denn an künstlichen Sachen einbauen?
Was ich mir an künstlichen Sachen einbauen würde, wäre es schwierig. Da mich das Thema selber auch ein bisschen betrifft mit dem Brainport, weil ich selber auch blind bin, ich hab das vergessen zu erwähnen, wäre das natürlich eine sehr interessante Sache, auch wenn es da irgendwie was geben würde. Sagen wir mal eben einen Chip, der eben ein künstliches Auge darstellen kann und eben auch eine entsprechende Funktion übernehmen könnte an den Sehnerven.
Entschuldige, darf ich mich fragen, bist du seit Geburt an blind?
Das ist eine Sehnerven-Atrophie, das heißt also meine Sehnerven sind im Endeffekt nicht genügend, sich blutet, aber sonst ist eigentlich alles da, was ich brauchen würde, um sehen zu können.
Das heißt, du würdest dir aber sozusagen ein künstliches Bild erzeugen, da würdest du mitmachen?
Ich würde mitmachen, wenn dabei kein gesundheitliches Risiko bestehen würde. Also wenn man wirklich ausschließen könnte, ist doch wirklich eigentlich schon genügend erforscht wäre, dass man sagen könnte, okay, da ist wirklich das Risiko sehr gering.
Also du willst kein Alpha-Tester sein?
Also bei sowas, wo man wirklich eingreift in den Kafa und auch gerade im Gehirnbereich, nee, weil da wär's mir wirklich zu gefährlich, irgendwie dann am Ende irgendwelche Einschränkungen davon zu tragen, die vielleicht noch wesentlich erheblicher sind.
Aber wenn du blind bist, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich unheimlich viel übers Gehör machen. Könntest du dir vorstellen oder würdest du dich da eher behindern, dein Gehör in bestimmter Art und Weise durch Elektronik zu verbessern und dadurch zusätzliche Informationen zu bekommen, die dir den Umgang in deiner Umgebung erleichtern? Oder würdest du das eher hinderlich finden, weil du denkst, das Gehör brauch ich so wie es ist und da brauch ich keine Verfälschung oder so?
Ja, also ich finde, man sagt ja immer, wenn ein Sinn nicht da ist, auch gerade von Geburt an, geben die anderen Sinne wirklich alles Mögliche dazu, um das zu kompensieren. Und ich werde oft gefragt, ob ich dann vielleicht besser hören würde, weil ich eben nicht sehen kann. Das ist natürlich schwer zu beantworten, weil ich natürlich keinen Vergleich habe. Aber ich bin eigentlich so mit meinem Gehör, wie es ist, sehr zufrieden.
Die Idee der Frageschuldige, wenn ich dich nicht unterbreche, war, ob du lieber über welches Sinnesorgan du denn lieber die visuellen Informationen aufbereitet haben möchtest. Also ob dir vielleicht so ein Abbild des Raumes, wo dir Schall hinprojiziert wird und dir versucht, ein Bild, einen Eindruck von dem Raum zu verschaffen, lieber wäre oder lieber so ein Elektroden-Pad auf der Zunge.
Oder was auf dem Bauch mit lauter Kontakten drauf, wo du auf dem Bauch spürst, wo um dich rum möglicherweise Hindernisse sind, auf die du gerade zurennst oder sowas.
Also es ist schwer zu sagen. Ich meine, das ist ja auch was, wenn man wirklich sagt, okay, was ist am Alltag auch wirklich noch praktisch und umgänglich und was behindert einen nur. Also wenn ich jetzt die Auswahl hätte, jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwie mir was auf die Zunge zu legen oder mich mit allen möglichen Elektroden zu verkabeln, würde ich natürlich sagen, ja, probier ich lieber erst mal das Patch irgendwie aus, was man sich auf die Zunge drauflegt, weil es doch am einfachsten auch wieder abzunehmen ist, wenn man das doch sagt.
Benutzt du denn gerade schon elektronische Hilfsmittel, die dir irgendwie das orientieren, was normalerweise Sehende mit den Augen machen erleichtern?
Also ich weiß, es gibt viele Helfer mit Ultraschall oder auch Navigationsbereiche. Es ist die Frage, wo man jetzt sagt, wo fängt das Hilfsmittel an und wo hört das auf? Also ich finde zum Beispiel, dass sein iPhone ein sehr großes Hilfsmittel sein kann aufgrund der verschiedenen Erste, die es auch da im Moment gibt, gerade auch im Navigationsbereich.
Robin, das Problem ist, dass wir hier immer diese ärgerlichen Nachrichten zwischendurch haben, wo wir diese Pause machen müssen. Tatsächlich ist es so, dass wir über dieses Thema, also welche technischen Geräte gibt es heute schon, die möglicherweise so was Ähnliches sind wie eine Cyberprothese, nachher in der Sendung noch sprechen wollen. Können wir dich einfach später nochmal anrufen? Super, dann stell dich kurz raus, der Kaietan schreibt deine Nummer auf und nachher, wenn es um dieses Thema geht, rufen wir dich nochmal an. Und sprechen jetzt noch ganz kurz mit dem Martin von den Nachrichten ja noch was zu dem Zungenseeding ergänzen will. Hallo Martin.
Ja hallo, und zwar dieser Zungensensor, der wird glaube ich schon vom US-Militär erforscht. Da geht es denn darum, dass zum Beispiel Kampftaucher auf der Zunge diesen Sensor haben, quasi um einen Höhenmesser etc. drin zu haben, dass sie ihre Augen weiterhin näher nutzen können, um zu sehen. Also man wird ja denn im Sinne auch multitaskingfähig, wenn man einen zusätzlichen Sensor drin hat. Man könnte jetzt, wenn man das weiterführen würde, zum Beispiel auch Nachrichten auf der Zunge empfangen. Und könnte ja trotzdem nicht wie mit dem Handy, muss aufs Handy gucken, sondern kann sich ganz normal im Alltag bewegen. Also der Zungensensor, denke ich mal, da bietet sich sehr viele Möglichkeiten.
Zumal man denkt, den Geschmackssinn, ja eigentlich nur dann braucht man wirklich was essen. Das heißt, du glaubst auch, dass wir bald alle mit einem digitalen Lolli rumlaufen, der uns ständig Informationen auf die Zunge bringt?
Ist ein bisschen eklig, dann mal so ein Stück, ich sag mal, Plaste jetzt in den Mund zu nehmen.
Das labbert man dann wie zur Seite noch raus?
Ja, er hat noch ein paar Nachteile. Außerdem ist noch ein Kabel dran, aber ich denke mal, wenn man das noch ein bisschen aufhört, dann noch ein bisschen mehr Technik mal dran.
Über Funk und dann schmeckt es ein bisschen nach Zitrone, dann geht dazu.
Ja, na irgendwie, das ist bestimmt schon ein bisschen abartig, wenn man die ganze Zeit damit im Mund rumhört. Obwohl es halt so viele Möglichkeiten mit sich bringt, also wenn man jetzt noch einen Film auf der Zunge spürt, ist das garantiert schön. Angenommen, man könnte sich jetzt zum Beispiel einen Film angucken, kann jetzt noch mal durch die Straßenbahn laufen oder so. Und es soll wohl so ein ähnliches Gefühl sein wie Brausepulver auf der Zunge.
Das sind halt Elektroden, die zersetzen das so auch ein bisschen von der obersten Schicht der Zunge. Klar, dass das schön prickelt, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich das auf Dauer wieder mit mir rucke.
Das geht bestimmt auch thermisch oder mechanisch.
Man nimmt es ja eigentlich, weil dort die Nervenzellendichte so hoch ist. Es gibt noch andere Stellen am Körper, da kommt man nicht so leicht ran. Aber vielleicht irgendwo sonst wo noch Nerven rausgucken, so im äußeren Hirnbereiche, dass man sich da vielleicht schon mal so ein Port wie einer Matrix einfach schon mal organisiert und dann da den Stecker da ranstecken.
Zusätzliche Sinne gibt es also auch. Haben wir zumindest gerade beim Zungen. Das kann also nicht zum Bildermacher verwendet werden, sondern auch für ganz andere Nachrichten. Da würden wir gleich noch drüber sprechen, was es da noch so gibt, also einen zusätzlichen Sinn, die der menschliche Körper jetzt gar nicht bietet, die man sich aber vielleicht dazu bauen kann. Aber bevor wir das machen, gibt es das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Heute das Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club in Gestalt von Frank Steini und Erdgeist. Hallo und willkommen zurück. Und es geht heute um Maschinenmenschen, also die Sache, dass man sich technisch in den Körper einbaut, um sich zu erweitern, etwas zu ersetzen, was verloren gegangen ist oder vielleicht ganz neue Dinge zu lernen. Wir haben gerade schon darüber gesprochen, was für Dinge, die der menschliche Körper so schon kann, was man da dranbauen könnte. Es fehlte noch ein bisschen irgendwie das Gehirn. Kann man Hirnschäden technisch ausgleichen? Kann man das Gehirn in irgendeiner Form schon erweitern?
Ja, das fängt jetzt an. Es gab jetzt, das ist noch gar nicht so lange her, war zwei Monate oder so, habe ich einen Bericht gelesen, da haben sie ein Chip gebaut, ein neuronales Netz, das feuert auf die gleiche Art und Weise, wie der Hippocampus das normalerweise tut. Und dann haben sie eine Ratte den Hippocampus zerschossen. Und haben erst geguckt, wie verhält sich das Viech dann. Es war also ein Desaster offenbar. Genauer Details kenne ich jetzt auch nicht. Es war ein sehr magischer Bericht, nicht wahr? Also das ist alles so ein bisschen Fuzzy. Vielleicht weiß das ja auch da draußen jemand genauer. Jedenfalls haben sie dem dann diesen Chip eingebaut, dieser Ratte, und haben die dann mit den Nervenbahnen des Gehirns verbunden und damit sozusagen eine Gehirnprothese hergestellt. Und diese Ratte hat diese Gehirnprothese wohl offenbar benutzt und sich danach wieder normal verhalten. Wobei ich persönlich glaube, das ist jetzt nicht so ganz das, was wir eigentlich meinen, sondern da geht es um eine Funktion, wo ein Teil des Gehirns eine bestimmte Taktrate vorgibt und bestimmte Mechanismen automatisiert eben feuert, damit das sozusagen in einem bestimmten Takt funktioniert. So stelle ich mir das zumindest vor. Ich bin da kein Neurologe oder sowas.
Also quasi sagen, einfache Funktionen.
Einfache Funktionen, die dann nachempfunden werden, die dann zu wieder einer Normalfunktion führen. Was auf jeden Fall funktioniert, ist, dass bestimmte Areale im Hirn über Elektroden gereizt werden. Und dann die Leute aufgrund dieser Reizungen bestimmte Empfindungen haben oder bestimmte Handlungen vornehmen. Das macht man bei bestimmten Arten von Hirn-OPs jetzt schon, dass die Leute sozusagen nur mit einer Lokalanesthesie betäubt werden. Dann kriegen sie eben die Schädeldecke geöffnet. Und dann werden, weil wenn die zum Beispiel jetzt, ja sorry, wenn die jetzt halt einen Tumor operieren wollen, müssen sie ja gucken, dass sie keine wichtigen Teile verletzten. Dazu muss der Patient bei Bewusstsein sein. Dann reizen die mit Elektronen die verschiedenen Areale und stellen dann fest, aha, und dann hebt er die rechte Hand. Dann hebt er die linke Hand, je nachdem, wo das ist. Und dann weißt du, aha, okay, oder dann reizt du da. Dann wird der Patient gefragt, wie er sich fühlt. Und dann sagt er, jetzt wird es eben heiß da und da. Und jetzt empfindet er das und das. Manchmal sagt er auch unwillkürlich irgendwelche Dinge usw. Und dann wissen sie durch die Reizung, welches Areal gerade wofür da ist und wo sie jetzt besser nicht schneiden, weil dann kann der hernach die Hand nicht mehr heben.
Das ist echt gruselig.
Witzig daran ist, kleine Seitenstory, dass sie die Leute hinterher gefragt haben, warum sie denn die rechte Hand gehoben haben und die total vernünftige, plausible Erklärung hatten, warum es aus ihrer Sicht völlig selbstverständlich war, dass sie aus freiem Willen die Hand gehoben haben. Das heißt, die wussten nicht, dass sie die Hand gehoben haben, weil da sie jemand gereizt hat. Und wenn es nicht so schön ist, waren sie selbst der Meinung, es gab einen guten Grund dafür. Das Gehirn hat sich das so wieder zusammengereimt, dass es dann als Story doch passte, warum sie die Hand gehoben haben.
Also dein freier Wille ist die Begründung, warum es hinterher passiert ist.
Genau.
Es gab da noch diesen coolen Spruch, der war da, du bist nicht König über deinen Gehirn, sondern eher so dieser Typ, dieser komische, der dahinter steht und meint, excellent choice, your majesty.
Also das ist echt gruselig, sagt man einiges über freien Willen aus.
Da gibt es ja noch diese andere Gehirnstimulationstechnik, wo man die Schildedecke nicht öffnen muss. Das ist die transkraniale Magnetstimulation, wo man mit kleinen, sehr starken Magnetspugeln bestimmte Hirnareale reizt. Und das war eigentlich auch ziemlich gruselig, weil man muss halt nicht in den OP sauber sein, sondern kriegst halt so eine kleine Mütze auf, wo halt irgendwie so eine Spule dran ist.
Nein, das sind so zwei große Plastikspugeln, die sind schon faustgroß, diese Spugeln.
Ja gut, aber vergleichsweise klein für die Fälschdiagnose, die sie da durchpusten. Und damit kann man halt auch alles Mögliche machen, also alle möglichen Hirnareale reizen oder unterdrücken. Und natürlich sind unsere liebten Militärs- und Sicherheitsbehörden gerade wieder dabei, irgendwie was zu bauen, dass man nicht lügen kann. Das ist sehr praktisch für die Verhöre. Aber was sie halt unter anderem auch gefunden haben, ist ein Zentrum, was irgendwie so ungefähr beim Drittel der Probanden, wenn man es stimuliert, religiöse Empfindungen, Marienerscheinungen und sowas auslöst.
Also Halluzinationen halt.
Was meinst du wohl, was bei euch da denn erscheinen würde?
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Spaghetti-Mons?
Wir sind halt, was jetzt irgendwie so nützliche Hirnimplantate angeht, also was ich ja zum Beispiel echt gerne hätte, wäre sowas wie ein Gesichts- und Namengedächtnis. Dass man halt einfach merken kann, wie heißt denn dieser Typ da zu einem Gesicht gehört.
Und vor allem, worüber habt ihr das letzte Mal geredet?
Ja klar, wir haben das letzte Mal geredet. Das wäre wirklich sehr praktisch. Aber davon sind wir da wohl noch ein bisschen entfernt. Und die Frage ist halt eben auch, ob man sowas wirklich einbaut ins Gehirn oder ob man es lieber als exogene Proteine hat.
Ich würde mir das lieber flüstern lassen. Hey, das ist der Klaus. Aber was es gibt, ganz andere Bereiche. Sie haben auch wieder Mäusen, haben sie Elektroden in ihr Lustzentrum eingebaut und konnten den dann per Schalter in Orgasmus verpassen. Und dann haben sie mal geprüft, welcher Trieb wohl stärker ist. Und dann hatten sie halt so ein Gitter, haben sie unter Strom gesetzt, ordentlich. Das hat also richtig gebratzelt und die Mäuse, auf der anderen Seite war es Futter. Und bei der einen Gruppe Mäuse, bei der anderen Gruppe Mäuse war auf der anderen Seite der Schalter, wo sie sich einen verpassen konnten. Und die Mäuse in der Hungergruppe, wo das Futter auf der anderen Seite war, die sind nicht über dieses Gitter. Die sind lieber gestorben, als über dieses Gitter zu laufen. Aber die, die wussten auf der anderen Seite, ist der Lustknopf, die sind darüber wie nichts Gutes. Und zwar die ganze Zeit in einem Vorrat. Und haben versucht, so oft wie möglich auf diesen Knopf zu drücken.
Alter Schwede, da dachte ich nicht, dass wir heute Abend hinkommen. Das sind schon sehr bedenkliche Dinge. Ich möchte wieder zurück zu den einfachen Prothesen kommen, bevor ich mich hier...
Ach, da gibt es noch ganz andere spannende Prothesen.
Ja, aber über deine Rakete sprechen wir auch ein anderes Mal. Wir haben jetzt nämlich Patrick am Telefon, 29, aus Berlin. Und der arbeitet anscheinend bei jemand, der so eine Prothesen herstellt. Hallo Patrick.
Hallo Patrick.
Patrick, Entschuldigung.
Ja, das ist ein großes Medizintechnikunternehmen. Und die haben am Potsdamer Platz eine Präsenz. Quasi ein Museum, eine Ausstellung, wo man rein kann und sich das dann gucken kann. Ja, und eben da geht es auch sehr viel um Bionik.
Und erzähl doch mal ein bisschen.
Das Coolste sind sehr viele Sachen. Das kommt immer drauf an, wer dann gerade so reinkommt. Aber so die Sachen, die einen schon vom Hocker hauen können, da gehört definitiv die Gedanken oder intuitiv gesteuerte Armprothese dazu.
Wie werden die Signale abgenommen, um die zu steuern?
Ja, über Muskelelektroden eigentlich. Das Ganze wird über einen Umweg gemacht, in dem eine Operation durchgeführt wird, wo Nervenenden an Muskelpartien umgelegt werden. Die kriegen eine neue Funktion, also sozusagen Brustbruskulatur wird...
Die wird nach außen auf die Haut geführt, oder was?
Nein, das bleibt alles unter der Haut. Man will ja nicht irgendwelche offenen Wund stellen. Man legt einfach die Nervenenden ab dem Stumpf eben an, um zu funktionieren, Brustmuskeln oder Muskeln an. Und dann wachsen die dann ein. Dann gibt es verschiedene Bereiche, die da definiert, wo man dann tatsächlich fühlt. Da ist jetzt der kleine Finger oder der große Finger.
Werden dann auch wirklich tatsächlich die Nerven benutzt, die früher mal zum Finger gingen?
Naja, halt ab der Stelle, wo die eben da sind. Und dann wachsen die eben, man trennt die Nerven, die eben zu dem Brustmuskel gehen durch, operiert dann, je nachdem, Nerv an Nerv an. Das sind genau vier Stück an der Stelle. Und die wachsen dann den Weg wieder ein in die Brustmuskulatur und suchen sich dann halt ihren Platz. Und je nachdem, was dann da an Stellen entstehen, kriegt man auch Muskelsignale für eben Bewegung. Wenn der an irgendeine Bewegung mit dem Phantomarm denkt, dann kontrahiert der Muskel.
Und das kann man dann abnehmen.
Genau, und wenn man ihn dann eben antippt, dann spürt er da auch so ein diffuses Gefühl von, da wird jetzt der kleine Finger oder so was berührt.
Okay, ja genau, das ist cool.
Mit viel Training, aber er muss sich dann schon überlegen, dass der sich den Phantomarm quasi bewegt. Geht das gut mit dem Nervenwachstum? Das dauert eine ganze Weile, so drei bis zwölf Monate, sagt man. Und dann sind die eben eingewachsen. Man findet dann, je nachdem, wie gut er das trainiert, je nachdem, wie gut die Nerven wachsen, verschiedene Bereiche und kann dann die Technik mit Informationen versorgen. Und im Prinzip ist dann der Brustmuskel eben die Datenlieferstelle für die Technik im Arm und die Prothese kann dann so bewegt werden, wie man es gewohnt ist. Quasi noch nicht mit allen kleinen Fingerbewegungen. Also wie du vorhin gesagt hast, mit dem Klavierspielen, das ist momentan noch nicht drin. Aber zumindest muss man kein Menü mehr auswendig lernen.
Und die Stromversorgung von so einer Armprothese?
Ja das ist intern, da ist ein Akku drin.
Okay, also man lädt dann halt seinen Arm auf?
Ja genau, ganz normal. Das gibt es ja auch schon mit Beinprothesen, wo dann eben Mikrotechnologie drin ist, Sensormesstechnik und so weiter. Und dann packt man das eben abends an eine Steckdose und das hält dann noch mal zwei Tage, drei Tage, je nachdem, wie der Akku eben, welche Leistungsdauer der hat.
Aber das heißt dann, der Arm ist dann die ganze Zeit dran?
Ja klar, so wie jede Prothese, das setzt man sich halt an oder zieht es dann wieder ab.
Das meine ich, also wenn er ins Bett geht und sein Akku zum Aufladen sozusagen anschließt, dann ist der Arm nicht mehr dran.
Genau, dann nimmt er den einfach ab, steckt das in eine Steckdose und ja, dann setzt er es am nächsten Morgen wieder auf.
Und die Schnittstelle, von der du sprachst, also mit den Kabeln, die in den Brustmuskeln gehen, die ist dann sozusagen extra eingebaut?
Nein, nein, die Nerven, so wie ich das verstanden habe, ist, dass die Nerven, die eigentlich in deine Hand gingen, dass die da, wo der Arm ab ist, rausgenommen werden und umgelegt werden in den Brustmuskel und da unter der Haut liegen. Und dann, wenn die eingewachsen sind, prüft man hinterher, indem man an der Stelle tippst und so weiter, wie fühlt es sich denn an? Ist das jetzt der kleine Finger? Dann ist das Gefühl für den kleinen Finger auf deiner Brust an irgendeiner Stelle. Wenn ich da also antippse, dann fühlt es sich für dich so an, als wäre dein kleiner Finger berührt worden. Und da kommt jetzt also die Elektrode drauf, von der Prothese, die wird außen drauf geklebt.
Ja, was ich fragen wollte war, wie diese Schnittstelle ist zu der Prothese.
Das ist der Schaft, also sozusagen das, was eben die Prothese, ob es jetzt Bein oder Arm ist, am Stummfeld. Und das ist dann eben ein negativer Abguss. Und heutzutage eben in den meisten Fällen Kunststoff.
Genau, aber da sind dann so Kontakte drauf, die auf deine Brust andocken.
Elektroden, die da einfach drin sind und die dann eben mit dem Schaft die Haut berühren und da die Signale abmessen. Da muss man dann noch dafür sorgen, dass das alles an der richtigen Stelle liegt und dass das halt fest eingegossen da drin. Die werden halt kalt gezogen und dann ist das da einfach fest drin.
Die Frage, die ich habe, ich kann es mir immer noch nicht ganz forschen, die Frage, die ich habe, ist, gibt es einen künstlichen Bestandteil dieses neuen Armens, der immer an dem Körper dran ist? Nein, das gibt es noch nicht. Man nimmt es komplett ab und die Elektroden kommen weg.
Momentan hat man einfach die Möglichkeit, dass man das abnimmt. So Sachen, dass man tatsächlich mit Kabeln unter die Haut geht, das möchte man ja vermeiden. Das sind ja offene Wunschstellen. Das einzige, wo es funktioniert, sind halt Zähne. Da geht es vom Knochen durch die Haut und Zähne putzen hilft. Aber das jetzt irgendwo auf der Haut zu haben, das wäre halt schon ein Problem. Das kommt drauf an. Je nach Länge, sagt man, ist schon deutlich einfacher, also leichter als der eigene Arm. So Prototypen, da waren es noch um die sechs Kilo. Und um es richtig alltagstauglich zu haben, dann muss es so um die drei Kilo, vier Kilo sein.
Und die Batterie ist in dem Arm drin, oder trägt man die extra im Gürtel oder so?
Nee, natürlich mit drin. Also alles so, dass man das dann eben auch einfach benutzen kann. Willst ja nicht noch eine extra Pasche oder so was dabei haben.
Und gibt es ein Haus, wo du mal was sagen kannst, wie teuer sowas ist?
Das hängt immer davon ab. Neue Technik ist natürlich viel, viel teurer als das, was jetzt eben schon Standard ist. Also guck dir halt, mit Telefonen ist das ja ähnlich. Das, was jetzt gerade neu aus der Technik kommt, das kriegst du für 500 oder 600 Euro. Und so ein altes Nokia kriegst du für 20 Euro. Natürlich ist das jetzt grob gesagt, aber allein das System allein entscheidet ja schon, wie viel das kostet. So eine mechanische Prothese, die eben autark von Strom funktioniert, ist schon deutlich günstiger als eine mit Mikrotechnologie. Aber dann hängt es halt auch immer davon ab, was kann derjenige und wo will der dann damit hin.
Aber kannst du nicht mal so nach Haus noch mal sagen? Also irgendwie jetzt das Luxusmodell von...
Ja, so einen kleinen Wagen. Das kommt halt wirklich drauf an. Beim Prothesenbein mit Mikrotechnologie, da könnte man eben sagen so 18.000, 25.000, je nach Beinlänge kommt halt wirklich drauf an. Das geht schon auch noch ein bisschen höher. Dann kann man noch sagen, kriegt derjenige noch eine schöne Kosmetik dazu, wo dann wirklich so alles mit Silikon und einzelnen Pigmenten und eben echten Haaren dran ist, damit das sehr authentisch aussieht. Das sind dann halt die teuren Sachen.
Bezahlt das die Krankenkasse?
Ja, doch. Also das gehört halt zur Standardversorgung dazu. Und wenn man es braucht, dann bekommt man das auch.
Und was ist so der Stand der Dinge bei Beinprothesen?
Ja, also das, was so modern ist oder das, was halt Standard ist.
Nee, das, was so der Top-Edge ist, also was jetzt grad so geht.
Das, was grad so geht, das sind ja Prothesen, die ein intelligentes Gen mit drin haben, die schon wissen, in welche Bewegung du reingehen möchtest. Du möchtest Treppen steigen. Eine mechanische Prothese ist ein gedämpftes Pendel, das immer wieder an die Ausgangslage geht. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt mit deinem Bein die Treppe hochwollen würdest, würde das eben ein gestrecktes Bein sein. Und das weiß nicht, jetzt soll es einknicken, damit du es auf die nächste Stufe heben kannst. Und die Technik würde das dem Bein dann eben sagen, über Regelmesstechnik und Lagesensoren kriegst du das mit. Und dann würde das Bein gehoben werden und im richtigen Moment auf die nächste höhere Treppenstufe gesetzt werden. Also das ist das, was mit drin ist. Oder du kannst dann halt in Modus umschalten, wo du Fahrrad fahren kannst oder... Ja, Fliegschuh laufen kannst. Je nachdem, was du möchtest, das stellt dir dann aber der Orthopädietechniker ein.
Ja, aber ist klar. Ich meine, wenn Aibo Treppen laufen kann, sollte das so eine Prothese auch können.
Ja, na klar. Und da das Laufen ja noch deutlich einfacher ist als das Greifen, lässt sich da natürlich viel, viel mehr sehr einfach von außen, sieht jetzt sehr einfach aus. Steckt natürlich viel Technik drin. Sehr, sehr einfach dann regeln.
Was mich da noch interessiert ist, wenn die Batterie in dem Bein erstmal alle ist, kann man dann noch irgendwie unschön nach Hause humpeln oder ist man dann erstmal hilflos irgendwo?
Na, schon so. Also es ist schon so, dass dann tatsächlich das Bein steif schaltet, wenn der Akku alle werden würde. Da gibt es dann allerdings auch unterschiedliche Sachen, dass man zum Beispiel bei den neueren Modellen jetzt so eine Art Vibrationsalarm mit drin hat. Das dann sagt, so jetzt noch sechs Stunden Batterie und dann lad mal wieder auf. Aber das passiert nach zwei Tagen erst.
Aber wie ist es denn so zu sagen, wenn du trotzdem in die Verlegenheit kommst?
Ja, dann macht das Bein sich steif. Und dann kann man eben noch laufen damit, aber man kann es eben nicht mehr so dynamisch bewegen wie vorher. Also wenn du vorher mit 6 kmh über die Straße geflitzt bist, um den Bus noch zu kriegen, geht das dann eben nicht mehr.
Nicht schlecht.
Das ist wie das Notrad.
Patrick, dann vielen Dank für diese Einblicke. Ist ja echt krass, wie weit wir schon sind. Ihr seid durch oder wollt ihr noch was von Patrick wissen?
Ja, mit dem künstlichen Arm, das erinnert mich ans D-Larg. Das ist so ein Medienkünstler, der hat sich mal so eine Armprothese als dritten Arm angeschraubt und dann gelernt, irgendwie seinen Arm mit drei Händen, seinen Namen mit drei Händen gleichzeitig an die Tafel zu schreiben. Da gibt es ein Video auf YouTube, sehr bizarr, wie er da mit drei Händen sozusagen auf der Tafel rumkippelt.
Und das war dann auch über so eine Elektro-Kontakte?
Das war damals noch über Muskelkontraktionen, die er wirklich lernen musste. Das hat er dann irgendwie geübt und konnte dann mit diesem Arm fernsteuern.
Jetzt haben wir also schon erfahren, dass das Ersetzen von Gliedmaß und auch teilweise in Sinnen angeht, wir schon relativ weit vorn sind. Wie ist es denn jetzt mit Extrasinnen?
Ja, da gibt es ein schönes Beispiel. Wir hatten vorhin schon eins genannt, eben mit dem Magneten in dem Finger.
Das ging aber auch nicht besonders gut aus, oder?
Nein, das ging nicht gut aus.
Wieso, was war da?
Diese Magneten, die bestehen aus Neodymen und sind dann mit einem metallischen Mantel umzogen. Und dieses Neodym ist halt nicht völlig ungefährlich. Und nun zersetzte also das Immunsystem dieser Frau, diesen Magneten, diese Schicht außen rum, sodass der halt zerbröselte in diesem Finger und das dann zu einer Blutvergiftung führte und sie den ganz schnell rausnehmen lassen musste, weil das sonst im Desaster geendet wäre. Und sie hat dann auch keinen neuen reinmachen lassen, aber sie konnte zum Glück noch davon berichten, dass es eine sehr beeindruckende Erfahrung ist. Aber nun gibt es ja auch andere Wege, wie man solche Sinneseindrücke vermitteln könnte. Man könnte sich ja jetzt auch einen Handschuh anziehen, sag ich mal, wo vorne ein Magnetfeldsensor drin ist Es geht doch viel einfacher.
Du klebst einfach mit Sekundenkleber einen Magneten auf den Fingernagel.
Ja, das geht auch. Hast du es schon probiert?
Ich hab's probiert. Ich hab nicht Sekundenkleber genommen, sondern einen ich wieder abholen konnte.
Heißkleber?
Nee, einfach einen normalen Kleber. Also dein Fingernagel ist erstaunlich sensitiv, gerade der vom Zeigefinger. Merkt man spätestens, wenn man sich mal draufgeklopft hat. Eine 220 Volt-Leitung merkt man schon, wenn man ein bisschen drauf achtet. Das ist durchaus möglich. Das ist nicht so sensitiv wie die Fläche des kleinen Fingers.
Aber das ist ja auch nicht elektronisch und deswegen langweilig. Da ist nichts digital dran. Nein, ein Handschuh mit einem Magnetfeldsensor vorne drin, der das eben möglicherweise sogar auch noch signalisiert, was das für eine Signalart ist, die da gerade an der Wand oder in dem Kabel. Du tastest also das Kabel ab und er sagt dir, hier ist das ISDN. Und dann tastest du am anderen und dann fühlst du, hier, das ist Ethernet. Und dann grabbelst du so an der Wand lang und dann weißt du, ach ja, guck mal, hier ist ein Stromkabel in der Wand. Wenn du jetzt auch noch einen Aktor hast, also am anderen Finger noch ein Geber, der sozusagen ein Wechselsmagnetfeld erzeugt, könntest du jetzt also mit zwei Fingern über die Wand streichen und spüren, wo dahinter das Metallrohr von der Wasserleitung ist.
Und wie kommuniziert so ein Handschuh dann?
Der würde dann über Vibratoren, also wie so kleine Vibratormotoren ein Signal am Handgelenk zum Beispiel oder im Finger, das könnte man ja so definieren, dass er einfach oder über ein Vibratormodul eben dir signalisiert über ein Muster von Vibrationen, was du da gerade spürst.
Jetzt hat Erdgeist ja schon mal ein anderes Modul getragen, was mit Vibratoren versehen war. Eine sehr spannende Geschichte, die du vor dem Chaosradio schon mal erzählt hast. Lässt du die Hörer auch noch mal daran teilhaben?
Na gut, ein paar Freunde an der Uni in Hamburg haben ein Gürtel fertig gebastelt, dem einmal, als auch meine Plaut so rumgepasst hat, in alle Himmelsrichtungen und dazwischen, also acht Motoren, die auch in den Mobiltelefonen verbaut sind, die da üblicherweise drin machen, wenn man angerufen wird. Die waren einmal rundum verteilt und ein Kompass, der vorne auf dem Gürtel mit drauf war und nach vorne geguckt hat, der wurde eins zu eins auf die Motoren umgemappt. Zum Anfang war es noch ein sehr intensives Gefühl. Da konnte ich mich einmal im Kreis drehen und dann drehte sich dieses Gefühl da, wo Norden ist, einmal um meinen Körper mit rum. Dann bin ich eine Weile mit rumgelaufen, dann sollte ich das runter regeln und nach so ungefähr anderthalb Tagen war dieses Gefühl einfach nicht mehr bewusst wahrzunehmen, sondern nur noch ganz unterbewusst da. Aber es war total spannend, weil plötzlich hatte man so eine Möglichkeit, sich zusätzlich zu orientieren, wenn man irgendwo eine Straße runtergelaufen ist. Wenn mir gesagt wurde, da läuft dafür die Straße geradeaus und ich konnte da nicht mehr geradeaus weiterlaufen, bin ich irgendwie zweimal im Zickzack gelaufen. Normalerweise wäre man wieder total verwirrt, wie man jetzt weiterkäme. Aber ich wusste intuitiv, wo Norden ist. Das hat mir dann ziemlich geholfen, den Weg wieder zurückzufinden zu dem Ziel. Und nachdem ich dann nach vier Tagen dieses Experiment beenden musste, da stand ich dann echt ziemlich verwirrt rum. Also das war wie, weiß nicht, ob man einen Sinn amputiert. Kann man schwer beschreiben, aber es ist wirklich verwirrend.
Das ist relativ einfach zu schreiben. Kann man sowas auch zu Hause nachbauen?
Das versuche ich gerade zu Hause nachzubauen, aber die Prokrastination hat dazu geführt, dass das Projekt schon seit anderthalb Jahren rumliegt.
Darf ich dir eine Prothese geben für die Prokrastination? Wir machen das jetzt noch mal ehrgeizig.
Können wir vielleicht den Hörer von Vorhinder anrufen? Ich würde ihn gerne mal dazu befragen, wie er zum Beispiel als Blinde mit seinem iPhone navigiert. Das würde mich sehr interessieren. Den ersten Hörer, den wir da hatten.
Genau, Robin.
Womit wir dann ja aber auch gleich zu einem Thema kämen, ob wir nicht alle schon Body Enhancements eh in der Hosentasche haben.
Also folgender Plan, wir machen jetzt eine kurze Pause, weil es ja auch gerade schon wieder um elf ist. Sprechen dann kurz mit dem Dennis, der nämlich uns befragen möchte, wie es ist, wenn sich die Technologie verselbstständigen würde. Und dann gehen wir über zu dem Thema, wie ist denn das jetzt mit den Dingen, die jetzt noch nicht so sci-fi sind, weil wir sie für normal wahrnehmen, ob die nicht vielleicht auch schon so eine Art Körpererweiterung sind. Und bevor wir jetzt diese Pause machen, möchte der Herr Erdgeist gerne noch ein weiteres Ergebnis einer Prothesenerfahrung mit uns teilen.
Ach ja, da viele von den Dingen, die man heutzutage an Elektronik oder Elektrik mit sich rumschleppt, um dort zusätzliche Drucke in die Umgebung zu erzeugen. Eine davon ist eine Stromgitarre, mit der kann man seine Gedanken in Musik umsetzen. Das hab ich hier auch eine Weile lang erfolgreich getan und dann ein Public Domain Musikstück von meiner ehemaligen Band mitgebracht, was der Marlboro selbst spielen möchte.
Heute das Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club und zu Gast sind Steinj Frank und Erdgeist. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und es geht heute um Menschen, die sich Technik einbauen lassen. Maschinenmenschen, könnte man sagen. Und die verschiedenen Möglichkeiten, die wir heute schon haben, die es vielleicht noch geben wird. Und vor allem auch, welche Konsequenzen das haben könnte. Wir haben uns die erste Stunde damit beschäftigt, ein bisschen genauer herauszufinden, an welchen Teilen des Menschen im Körper man solche Sachen überhaupt anbauen kann. Und dann auch gerade von jemanden, der in so einer Firma arbeitet, die Prothesen herstellt, erzählt bekommen, wie zum Beispiel, wie weit künstliche Beine eigentlich schon vorangeschritten sind. Sodass man auch schon schittschuhlaufen fahren, schittschuhlaufen kann, Herrgott. Und wollen uns jetzt ein bisschen den Konsequenzen dieser Technologie widmen und die sich damit verbinden, dass man in seinen Körper auch Technik reintun kann. Und das natürlich immer, wenn es um Technik geht, die eine Frage, was ist denn, wenn die nicht mehr funktioniert. Und deswegen hat auch Dennis angerufen aus Dorsten. Hallo und guten Abend, Dennis.
Was ist denn deine Frage oder dein Beitrag?
Ich habe mich etwas längere Zeit halt mit mit den ganzen Mikroprozessoren beschäftigt und irgendwann kam ich dann halt oder beschnitt sich das Ganze mit exploit. Und für mich persönlich stellt sich dann die Frage, wenn das Ganze doch irgendwann von der Mikrotechnik oder beziehungsweise von irgendeinem Prozessor verarbeitet wird und das Ganze mechanisch weitergegeben wird, inwieweit ist es dann eigentlich möglich oder rein hypothetisch betrachtet, dass dafür auch irgendwann eines Tages exploits geschrieben werden? Das heißt, dass die Leute, ja, da kann man jetzt wirklich sagen, ob das jetzt vielleicht ein visueller Reiz ist, ob das vielleicht ein chemischer Reiz ist, den man wie vorhin vielleicht besprochen über irgendein Lolli einnimmt oder vielleicht über eine USB-Schnittstelle, die sich dann hinterher verselbstständig irgendwelche Geschichten, was wäre denn dann eigentlich?
Das Krasse ist, dass nach der gängigen Lesart der Staat sich das ja sogar rausnimmt. Der meint ja, dass er auf dein Computer rumschnüffeln möchte, weil du das schon vorher verschlüsselst. Jetzt stell dir mal vor, du fängst da schon an, während du mit deinem Hörgerät, mit irgend jemandem auf der anderen Seite eine verschlüsselte Kommunikation veranstaltest. Dann will der nach dieser Lesart auch auf dein Hörgerät, auf dein Implantat drauf, um dann voller Verschlüsselung schon abzunehmen, was du da gedacht hast.
Oder wenn du ein Exoskelett hast, dann läuft dich das zur Polizeiwache. Dann stell mal vor, also ich meine, Exoskelette, also der Unterschied zwischen Endoprothese und Exoprothese ist, glaube ich, klar. Endo ist innen drin, also irgendwo eingebaut. Kniegelenken, Sprunggelenken, sonst irgendwas. Und Exo ist, wenn man es außen ran baut, eben wie der Arm, von dem wir vorhin sprachen. Und so, jetzt gibt es ja auch Exoskelette, also zum Beispiel ein komplettes Gestell, wo sich jemand Gehbehindert ist, der jetzt nicht völlig behindert ist, sondern der seine Beine nur eben schlecht bewegen kann oder auch nicht mehr genug Kraft hat und so weiter, sich da reinstellt, reingurtet und dann damit losläuft. Das wird entwickelt von diversen Firmen, Japan, China und so weiter, auch von amerikanischen Militärs, damit Soldaten eben irre weit laufen können und gigantische Lasten heben. Also 100 Kilo hochheben mit so einem Ding geht. Verstärkt einfach nur ähnlich wie ein Elektrofahrrad, deine Kraft um den Faktor 3, sagen wir mal. Und jetzt stellen wir uns vor, was passiert, wenn so ein Ding einen Bug hat. Oder wir stellen uns vor, was passiert, wenn das ein Virus hat und jemand sozusagen ein Stück Software abspielen lässt, mit dir in diesem Gestell drin.
Was es schon klar sagt, ist, wenn die Technik so nah an unseren Körper heranrückt, also an ihn, uns oder direkt an uns rückt, ist natürlich die ganze Frage der Software-Sicherheit und der Integrität der informationstechnischen Systeme, die wir da haben, wird dabei natürlich nochmal deutlich akuter. Und die interessante Frage ist in der Tat, sind wir denn wirklich villens gerade vernetzte Implantate oder Explantate, die also auch Schnittstellen zum Netz haben und zum Beispiel mit Informationen arbeiten, die von außen kommen, trauen wir uns denn schon wirklich, die in Positionen zu bringen, wo man den Körper damit beschädigen kann? Und die Antwort darauf ist natürlich, naja, wir werden es wahrscheinlich machen, obwohl wir es eigentlich besser nicht machen sollten.
Wir sehen es doch gerade schon an unseren Mobiltelefonen. Das ist ja eine Wanze, die wir freiwillig mit uns mit rumtragen, die die ganze Zeit unsere Informationen, zumindest unsere Positionen beim Provider lässt.
Aber es ist doch deine Schnittstelle in das Kollektiv, bewusst sein der Cyborg-Gesellschaft.
Es ist verdammt nützlich natürlich, aber trotzdem ist die Abwägung, die wir da getrieben haben, scheinbar schon deutlich in die Richtung, dass wir das in Kauf nehmen.
Ich würde aber jetzt bevor wir so sagen und die ganz theoretischen Ausflüchtungen verflüchten, noch mal fragen wollen, wie das mit konkreten Angriffen ist. Ich habe nämlich jetzt noch im Hinterkopf, dass ich irgendwann mal gelesen zu haben, dass ich weiß nicht, ob es Herzschrittmacher waren oder Insulin-Depote.
Es gibt mehrere Geschichten. Zum einen gab es Insulinpumpen, die ein Bluetooth-Interface haben und wo übers Mobiltelefon der Insulinstatus gemessen und übertragen und mit dem Krankenhaus gesynkt wird. Es gibt EKG-Geräte, die mit einem zentralen Server reden und wo aus der Ferne quasi ein eingebordter Defibrillator ausgelöst werden kann, wenn EKG-Scheiße aussieht.
Hatte der Busch sowas nicht?
Angeblich ja. Es war ein bisschen unklar, ob es die Fernsteuerung für ihn war oder das EKG-Scheiße war. Das war alles ein bisschen unklar. Und da gab es dann tatsächlich genau diesen Fall, also bei diesen ferngestellten EKG-Defibrillator-Geräten, der Server, auf dem diese Anwendung lief, mit dem die Geräte kommuniziert haben, der war halt in so einer Amazon-Cloud. Und dann fiel halt das Amazon-Data-Center runter, weil sie da so ein fundamentales Problem gelaufen sind. Und dann waren die Patienten da halt ohne entsprechende Absicherung beziehungsweise Monitoring.
Na, solange das Ding jetzt nicht den Defibrillator auslöst, mal ein Fass.
Also bei den Insulinpumpen ist das tatsächlich möglich. Es ist ja so, dass tatsächlich Leute gemacht haben, die selber betroffen sind, also die selber diese Pumpen hatten. Die haben die halt gehackt und haben halt festgestellt, dass es total trivial ist, wäre sich da selber mit umzubringen, indem sie halt einfach diesen Insulinpump auf Dauerfluss stellen.
Darbe Hilfe.
Und das ist tatsächlich ein Problem, was zunehmend ernster wird. Und wo also auch die Richtlinien für digitale Medizintechnik sind, dem momentan überhaupt noch nicht gewachsen.
Ja, aber du kannst ja jeden Herzschrittmacher mit geeigneten Magnetfeldern schon aus der Spur bringen.
Du kannst auch jedes Herz mit geeigneten Magnetfeldern aus der Spur bringen. Also am Ende ist es natürlich irgendwie der Körperverletzung, wenn du da irgendwie mit was draufhältst.
Ja, bloß der Punkt ist halt, wenn es halt, diese Dinger werden halt alle in der Hand angeschlossen sein. Also ist halt vollkommen klar, dass das Kommunikationsmedium über diese Prothesen, Exoprothesen, was auch immer kommunizieren wird, das Internet sein. Und wenn die Software darauf so scheiße ist, wie der Rest auf diesem Planeten, dann muss man sich schon ernsthaft überlegen, wie groß ist dann das Risiko tatsächlich, dass man sich da irgendwie in den Wurm fängt, irgendwie auf seiner Beinprothese oder irgendwie so. Was auch immer man da halt irgendwie gerade hat.
Das eröffnet auch Chancen, dass der Hersteller dann ein Abo verkaufen kann. Und wenn man dann mal nicht bezahlt, dann geht's halt nicht mehr.
Das sieht ja schön aus.
Oder wenn du nach Polen laufen willst.
Dennis, noch letzte Frage an dich. Würdest du dir trotzdem so Dinge einbauen lassen oder lieber nicht?
Und wenn ja, was?
Genau. Ich möchte jetzt keine Werbung machen, aber ich finde so eine Werbung von früher ganz cool. Da geht der Kopf auf, so eine Zeitschrift geht rein, takt birnen zu. Ich sag mal so eine Wikipedia vielleicht für den Kopf, aber mehr auch nicht. Vielleicht Altersverschleißer oder so, wenn man irgendwas an der Hüfte hat. Aber ich sag mal, da bin ich noch ein bisschen zu old school, um zu sagen, da steh ich zu sehr aufs Seilbock. Also nee, nee. Wobei ich mir auch noch den zweiten Gedanken gemacht hab, wie wäre das denn mit Wettkämpfen? Also wenn der Mensch tatsächlich dann halt hinterher so ausgestattet wäre, wie würde der Wettkampf heißen? Quad-Core-Prozess.
Eben dummerweise nicht beim Auto-Rennen. Ich meine, Formel 1 ist ja deswegen so langweilig, weil da noch Leute drin sitzen und sie die Engineers nicht machen lassen, wie sie wollen.
Die Frage ist, wenn es Wettkämpfe gibt, es gab ja mal ein Behinderten, der wurde disqualifiziert, weil er diese Prothesen getragen hat, wovon ihr vorhin gesprochen hattet. Wo hört das auf und wo fängt das an? Was heißt das hinterher? Heißt das dann hinterher nicht bis zu 80 Kilo Kampfklasse, sondern Quad-Core gegen einen anderen Prozessor?
Da wird es auf jeden Fall interessant.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist eher eine theoretische Situation, wo es dann möglicherweise um Wettkampfregelments geht. Aber die spannende Frage ist ja, ob das auch auf die Gesellschaft auswirken kann. Ob es irgendwann normal ist, jeder muss eine Prothese tragen, weil es halt total normal angesehen wird, dass man 80 Kilo heben kann und halt total gut hört.
Und wenn du 75 bist, dann musst du aber noch laufen können. Oder banal schon mal, wenn du das und das Implantat nicht hast, kommst du da und da nicht rein. Das wäre so mal so ein ganz trivialer Ansatz, dass du nur, wenn du dich über ein Implantat identifizieren lässt.
Ohne ihre Steueridentifikationsnummer.
Genau, kommst du einfach da in das Amt nähren.
Das wär doch überhaupt auch mal eine schöne Idee, oder? Nachdem wir jetzt alle Pässe schon mal Biometrie gesehen haben. Gibt es so eine Überlegung schon? Auf die Schädelplatte draufplanken oder so?
Na ja, die Fußfessel bei den digitalen Gefangenen, das ist ja im Prinzip schon so.
Da geht es gerade momentan noch umgekehrt, nämlich indem man die DNA als Identifikationsmerkmal benutzt.
Ich glaube, da war auch ein Club, der hat gesagt, irgendwie hier Erfurt implantieren.
Ja, das war aber Bullshit. Also das war tatsächlich ein Fake.
Mit den ganzen Kühen machen sie das schon.
Also die haben halt, was die getan haben, die haben tatsächlich einen Rinder-Tech genommen, also mit dem halt identifiziert werden und haben es als Eintritts für ihre Disco genommen. Und ein paar doofe Hipster haben es tatsächlich gemacht, dass sie sich so ein Ding haben in die Schulter schieben lassen. Und dann stellte sich halt irgendwie ganz schnell raus, dass man diese Text, weil es halt so eine billig Text waren, die wirklich für Vieh-Identifikation gedacht waren, problemlos klonen konnte und man sich dann halt auch nicht so was in die Schulter schieben musste, sondern einfach irgendwie eine kleine Karte, wo halt ein indischer Tag mit der Information drauf war. Benutzt hat, um da reinzukommen. Und dann haben sie es auch ganz schnell wieder abgestellt, aber irgendwie so 30 oder 35 Trottel hatten es dann doch irgendwie sich irgendwie reinschieben lassen.
Ja nun, aber die machen sie auch Pissings wohin.
Okay, auch ein anderes Chaosradio würde ich sagen. Körperschmuck. Dennis, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Jo, ich wünsche euch einen schönen Abend, allen Zuhörern auch und liebe Grüße an das ganze Team.
Danke, danke.
So, und dann kommen wir jetzt zu der Stelle, wo wir sagen, okay, es gibt diese ganzen Technologien und die Überlegung, dass man das möglicherweise mal also einbauen kann oder möglicherweise nur anschrauben, je nachdem, ob ENDO oder EXO, aber dass wir auch heute schon Technologien benutzen, die im Prinzip unsere Sinne und möglicherweise auch unser Wesen erweitern. Wir hatten vorhin schon kurz mit Robin gesprochen. Robin ist blind und hat erzählt, er nutzt sein Handy, sein iPhone, um irgendwie Dinge auf den Plan zu kriegen. Wir haben ihn jetzt noch mal hier in der Leitung. Hallo Robin, zurück. Jetzt wollte Frank wissen, wie du das Smartphone nutzt, um dir weiterhelfen zu lassen oder um dir selbst zu helfen.
Also erstmal zur Nutzung allgemein vom iPhone. Das ist jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen schwer sich vorzustellen, wenn man sich damit noch nicht so beschäftigt hat, weil schlussendlich basiert das iPhone hauptsächlich auf dem Touchscreen und klar, dann kann man natürlich nicht ohne eine bestimmte Hilfe bedienen. Jetzt ist es aber zum Glück so, dass Apple eigentlich wirklich heutzutage die einzige große Mainstream Software-Firma ist und Computer-Hardware-Firma ist, die sich wirklich hingesetzt hat und gesagt hat, okay, wie können wir die ganzen Produkte, die wir haben, also jetzt wirklich so iPhone, iPod, auch die ganzen Mac Computer, wie können wir die bedienbar machen für Leute mit irgendwelchen Behinderungen, Einschränkungen, auch ohne vorher irgendwie verklagt worden zu sein, weil da gibt es ja auch viel was da irgendwie. Und auf jeden Fall gibt es seit ein paar Jahren auch schon für das iPhone, kriegen wir das für das iPhone 3GS, ein Programm, das nennt sich VoiceOver, ist standardmäßig auch im iOS mit integriert. Also man braucht es wirklich nur in der entsprechenden Einstellung einzuschalten. Und das geht dann über eine Schwachausgabe. Also sprich, ich fahre mit meinem Finger eben über das Display und bekomme eben vorgelesen, wo ich gerade drauf bin, kann das dann doppelt antippen, nicht einmal wie es normalerweise wäre, sondern doppelt. Und das wird dann zum Beispiel geöffnet, zum Beispiel eine App oder so, oder irgendwas in der Art. Und damit kann man eben eigentlich das iPhone so benutzen, wie jeder andere auch. Das ist halt vom Bedienkonzept her ein bisschen eine andere Sache, weil es halt entsprechend auf die Sprachausgabe und die nicht visuelle Bedienung angepasst wurde. Aber das geht wirklich problemlos. Also ich hab auch damals zum iPhone 3GS angefangen. Und manche Leute sagen mir, ich wär mit dem Ding sogar schneller als sie mittlerweile, obwohl sie da drauf schauen können. Also das ist wirklich eine super Sache. Und damit lässt du das iPhone eigentlich auch nahezu uneingeschränkt nutzen.
Und wofür benutzt du es denn tatsächlich? Also auch für irgendwie, um dich zurechtzufinden?
Ja, also es gibt viele Firmen, also zum Beispiel Enzo, in Nordrhein-Westfalen wird das im Moment. Da gibt es ein sehr großes Projekt, was auch vom Landesvermessungsamt sehr stark unterstützt und eigentlich auch initiiert worden ist. Und die sind wirklich hergegangen und haben sich überlegt, okay, wie kann man jetzt ein Gerät nutzen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel das iPhone, um zum Beispiel damit einen Menschen eine nahezu uneingeschränkte Navigation zu ermöglichen, sowohl in der Stadt als auch in Gebäuden. Da gibt es verschiedene Ansätze. Einiges davon passiert im Moment halt noch auf GPS. Wobei GPS ja mit seiner maximalen Genauigkeit von, ich glaube, irgendwie sieben oder zehn Metern oder so jetzt nicht so optimal ist dafür. Es gibt aber auch zum Beispiel sowas, dass man einen RFID-Laser im Schuh hat. Also theoretisch könnte man sich das wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie in den Fuß implantieren oder so was, wo man dann durch die Gegend läuft. Und am Boden sind dann, das ist hauptsächlich für Gebäudenavigationen, entwickelt worden. Am Boden sind dann eben so bestimmte Tags, die einen dann eben darüber informieren, bzw. sie das dann über den Laser weitergeben, an ein iPhone zum Beispiel, wo man sich gerade genau befindet. Und da wird also sehr viel eigentlich gemacht, auch jetzt dann sobald Galileo dann irgendwie mal am Start ist, was wahrscheinlich eher länger als kürzer dauern wird.
Das kann noch ein bisschen dauern, ja.
Ja, aber da sind auch schon wohl Empfänger in der Entwicklung, die dann auch, also die dann alles irgendwie verbinden, also sowohl GPS als auch, es gibt da glaube ich noch irgendwie ein russisches Navigationssystem.
Das heißt aber, das Telefon ist für dich denn sozusagen schon zu so einer Sinneserweiterung geworden in dem Sinne?
Ja, also es ist halt, also es kann natürlich, im Moment so wie es jetzt ist, hauptsächlich mit GPS, kann es natürlich nicht irgendwie, sagen wir mal, die Navigation mit einem Stock oder auch mit einem Blindenhund oder sowas zu setzen, aber es ist schon zu einer sehr, sehr großen Hilfe und ja schon auch eine Art Erweiterung geworden. Also ich wollte mir jetzt nicht unbedingt ein iPhone, ein Computer, sage ich mal, ins Hirn implantieren, aber ich finde, dass es wirklich eine super Sache ist und auch wirklich extrem, extrem hilft. Also da wird doch im Mainstream Bereich sehr viel gemacht. Zum Beispiel Navigon, was ja auch für Fußgängernavigation genutzt werden kann, ist auch für Blinde bedienbar. Wenn auch natürlich vom Material her nicht so exakt, wie man es halt gerne hätte, aber es funktioniert.
Eine kurze Frage noch Robin, das heißt, du würdest das iPhone, wenn das abhanden kommen würde, wenn man es abnehmen würde, würdest du auch sagen, dann fehlt dir tatsächlich etwas?
Also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich ohne das Konzept aufgeschmissen wäre, aber klar, es würde natürlich schon was fehlen, klar, weil natürlich dann auch schon die Navigation zur nächsten Telefonzelle, wenn ich jetzt wirklich wo wäre, wo ich mich nicht auskenne, natürlich allein das schon schwierig werden würde. Wobei, da gibt es jetzt natürlich immer noch diese Menschen, die wieder bei rumlaufen.
Aber wenn du ein iPhone hast, brauchst du doch keine Telefonzelle, oder?
Ja, ne, das ist deshalb ja, wenn ich das iPhone weggenommen bekomme. Müsste ich ja irgendwie vielleicht Hilfe oder irgendwie das Ding anrufen zumindest. Wobei es gibt es auch, weil das auch so ein bisschen damit zu tun hat, es gibt auch Leute, gerade in Amerika, es gibt sowas, es nennt sich Extended 911, also das wenn man die 911 anwählt, da eben die Notfallstelle, dass man dann auch geortet werden kann, wenn man auf dem Handy aus anruft. Und es gibt tatsächlich in Amerika blinde Menschen, die sagen, wenn ich irgendwo auf der Straße verloren gehe, ruf ich da an und lasse mich orten, lasse mich dann von der Polizei einsammeln.
Das ist ein erweitertes Navigationssystem mit sozusagen auch noch emotionalen Fähigkeiten, nicht schlecht. Robin, dir vielen Dank für den Einblick in den Umgang mit noch externer Technik, die den Menschen erweitert. So, so unglaublich. Das finde ich sehr spannend. Ich hatte das vor dieser Sendung noch nicht, diesen Gedanken, dass man dann sagen konnte, okay, so das, was wir heutzutage benutzen, ist auch schon irgendwie ein Teil unseres Körpers.
Irgendwie, mein Gott, ohne das Mobiltelefon, was wir da ständig mit uns rumführen. Es ging ja irgendwie mit den armbandturen los. Das war da dann so ein präzises Zeitgefühl. Genau, hat uns geholfen so ein bisschen.
Na eigentlich kein Zeitgefühl. Eigentlich ist eine Uhr ja ein Synchronisationshilfsmittel. Also dass wir uns auf eine Zeit geeinigt haben und uns dieser synchronisierten Zeit gewahr werden. Ist ja keinen Sinn in dem Sinne.
Nee, es ist dann ein Sinn, wenn du einen Zeitraum abschätzt. Also wenn wir hier dauernd auf die Uhr gucken, wann es denn um halb ist, weil dann Nachrichten sind, dann ist das sehr wohl das Messen eines Zeitraumes. Also einer Zeitspanne von hier bis da.
Naja, aber wenn der Nachrichtensprecher nicht wüsste, dass es gleich halb ist, wäre es total egal. Deswegen ist es trotzdem nur eine Synchronisation.
Aber das Besondere dabei ist, dass man diese Uhr immer mit dabei hat. Sie war einfach um den Arm geschnallt und hattest du so deinen Augmented Time Sensor einfach immer mit dabei. Und irgendwann hatten Nerds irgendwie ihren Taschenrechner immer noch mit dabei. Und dann waren plötzlich ein Hygrometer, ein Barometer, ein Thermometer.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich finde diesen Unterschied schon interessant, weil die Uhr ist tatsächlich nur dann wichtig, wenn ich noch mit anderen Leuten zu tun habe. Also weil ich brauche eigentlich keine Uhr, wenn ich nur mit mir selbst unterwegs bin. Weil dann ist es halt echt egal, wie spät es ist.
Nö, also wenn es kalt wird.
Dazu kommt gerade der schöne Spruch, die Uhren sind die Trummler der Galerne der Neuzeit.
Aber man will vielleicht auch wissen, bevor es dunkel oder kalt wird, dass man dann irgendwie noch nach Hause zurückläuft. Das ist ja eine Tagessynchronisation. Dass du ungefähr weißt, wann Mittag ist, dass du ungefähr weißt, wie lange du gebraucht hast für irgendwas, dass ein Hinweg beim Wandern ungefähr genauso lange dauert wie ein Rückweg, ist schon wichtig.
Will ich aber trotzdem eine andere Kategorie packen als zum Beispiel ein Smartphone? Oder halt ein Computer?
Evolved halt.
Also interessant fand ich, ich hatte ja früher immer eine Uhr um den Arm, und zwar wegen der Sensor, nicht wegen der Uhr. Also mindestens ein Kompass musste schon sein, und eigentlich müsste es auch ein Barometer. Und das fand ich auch sehr nützlich. Und seit ich eben ein Smartphone habe, was all diese Funktionen quasi auch beinhaltet, habe ich halt keine Uhr mehr um, weil wozu auch? So, und eben die Menge an Daten und Informationen, die über so ein aktuelles Telefon verfügbar sind, also ich kann halt quasi in meinem Bett liegen, den Vorhang zulassen, auf meinem Telefon gucken, und ich weiß irgendwie, ob es da draußen regnet oder ob es gleich regnen wird.
Genau, ob es gleich regnen wird, das ist ja tatsächlich der.
Ich kann mit dem Regen gerade die Möglichkeit, das Wetter vorher zu sagen für mich persönlich, wo ich bin, ohne dass ich auch nur irgendwie aus dem Fenster gucken muss.
Ist schon krass, wie sich das gewandelt hat, dass am Ende in der Uhr der am wenigsten spannende Teil die Uhr selber ist und heute in den Telefon ist die langweiligste Abdehung, die ich auf meinem Telefon habe, ist diese blöde, das blöde Ding mit dem Hörer drauf, wo man nur eine eins zu eins Kommunikation mit irgendjemanden drehen kann, mit dem man sprechen muss.
Weil in Wirklichkeit verbindet mich dieses Smartphone ja mit meinem digital kollektiven Bewusstsein. Also mit meinen Freunden, mit Informationen aus dieser Welt da draußen, wo ich instantan erfahren kann, Dinge, die mich irgendwie womöglich betreffen oder zumindest emotional irgendwie tangieren. Und was der eine Anrufer vorhin meinte, naja natürlich, ich habe ja bereits ein Body Enhancement, das mir einen permanenten und unmittelbaren Zugriff auf Wikipedia ermöglicht. Ich kann ja auf das Weltwissen bereits zugreifen. Das heißt, diese ganzen heißen Debatten in den Kneipen, die sind heutzutage wahnsinnig kurz, da stellt sich irgendwie eine Frage und dann gucken drei Leute unterm Tisch nach. Wattet denn nun?
Man kann aber keine Scheiße mehr erzählen.
Und tun dann so, als hätten sie es selber gewusst.
Das ist wie auch für Politiker echt schwierig, weil wenn du nicht mit denen unterhältst und der erzählt dir irgendwas.
Fortgeschritten ist dann kurz vorher auf dem Klo noch die Wikipedia zu editieren, bevor man auf die Physik ist.
Wette gewonnen.
Aber das greift auch zu kurz einfach nur zu sagen, dass es einfach dein Sinnensorgan fürs Web ist. Weil da sind noch andere spannende Dinge dabei. Dein Mobiltelefon hilft dir auch Kram, was dein Kopf nicht so toll kann, wie zum Beispiel Bilder nehmen und sich merken, also präzise Bilder. Oder einfach Licht machen. Das war alles mit eingebaut. Da sind auch diverse andere Sensoren, wie gesagt der GPS-Sensor ist mit dabei. Du weißt, wo du bist. Du hast ein Recording Device, kannst dir da Gedanken entweder per Sprachnotiz oder per Notiz noch mit auf dein Mobiltelefon tun.
Ja, ist ein Gedächtnis schon auch. Ein Bildgedächtnis, ein Tongedächtnis und ein Informationsgedächtnis, durchaus.
Jetzt bringt das also sagen, wenn man das einen Schritt weiter denkt, eine spannende Frage auf. Nämlich jeder wäre sich, also eigentlich eine Hand darf man nicht abhauen. Also niemand, ich hab ein Recht auf meine Hände. Die darf man keiner wegnehmen.
Also da gab's Spiegelstrafen, Islam.
Wir reden jetzt hier Deutschland, so heute geteilt. Neuzeit Aufklärung, genau, Dankeschön. Würde ich dann auch sagen, quasi ein Smartphone, wenn man das so als Bodyenhancement beschreibt, ist ein Körperteil, wo man irgendwann sagen muss, das darf man eigentlich nicht mehr wegnehmen?
Ja, also wie sie sagen ja schon länger, also mindestens das Recht auf einen Computer und Internetanschluss mittlerweile wichtiger ist, als irgendwie das Recht auf einen Fernseher.
Ja, bei Weitem.
Bei Weitem, und dauert ja nun leider eine ganze Weile, bis sowas sich dann auch in dem allgemeinen Rechtsbewusstsein durchsetzt. Und bei Smartphones wird das in sehr kurzer absehbarer Zeit sehr ähnlich sein. Also das ist doch eine erhebliche Einschränkung ist, wenn man halt eben dieses Gerät weggenommen oder eingeschränkt bekommen kann.
Vor allem werden wir jetzt auch jede Menge Tools, externe Tools sehen, die an dieses Smartphone, das ich dann ja gar nicht mehr aus der Tasche nehmen muss, über Funk angebunden sind. Das Ding dann wie eine Zentrale agiert und mit Aktoren und Sensoren mich eben auch sozusagen in der Tasche über Dinge informiert. Oder dass zum Beispiel die Qualität meines Schlafes aufzeichnet über Sensoren in der Matratze zum Beispiel oder über Sensoren an meinem Handgelenk, die sehen, wie oft und wie viel ich mich bewege, über EKG oder EEG meine Schlafphasen messen kann.
Wenn du dann noch dein Telefon dazu bringen könntest, dass es dir langsam die Hormonausschüttung vorbereitet, bevor du aufstehen musst, dass es ein bisschen das Melatonin da abbaut schon in deinem Körper.
Bisschen das Licht hochfährt und ein bisschen Sonne, Vollspektrum Licht einschaltet und so weiter. Es gab einen Fall, da hat jemand sein Über auch über über ein Smartphone ab, über das nennt sich ja Quantified Self, kann man eine komplett eigene Sendung drüber machen, glaube ich. Das Beispiel nur, der hat halt seinen Puls immer aufgezeichnet und dann festgestellt, dass er auf dem Weg zur Arbeit an einer Stelle einen tierischen Puls hat und ist dann einfach mal einen anderen Weg gefahren. Das war halt irgendeine stressige Stelle an irgendeiner doofen Kreuzung. Dann ist er anders gefahren und seitdem fährt er mal völlig entspannt zur Arbeit. Ein bisschen weiter, aber viel entspannter. Das ist ja auch in gewissen Formen eine Art von Body Enhancement, sich sozusagen zu optimieren an solchen Stellen, den Schlaf zu optimieren, seine Nahrungsmittelaufnahme zu optimieren, deine Trainingsgewohnheiten, Sportgewohnheiten zu optimieren und auch den Erfolg davon zu prüfen, das Lungenvolumen zu testen, über einen Sensor beispielsweise, und dann zu gucken, ob bestimmte Maßnahmen erfolgreich sind und so weiter. Das ist auch in gewisser Form durch gezieltes Training mit digitaler Unterstützung auch Body Enhancement. Also letztlich ein Extra.
Jetzt finde ich es sehr spannend, dass wir die ganze Sendung über Body Enhancement reden, aber dass eigentlich all die Lösungen, die wir gehört haben, und auch, so habe ich zumindest das Gefühl, alle Lösungen, die ihr bevorzugen würdet, externe Lösungen sind. Das heißt also Sachen, die man sich anschnallt.
Das hat ja auch gute Gründe. Die sind einmal schon ganz kurz angeklungen. Next version will fix. Das heißt, wenn ich mir jetzt was einbauen lasse, was eine Operation verlangt, dann bin ich arschgekniffen, wenn es in einem Jahr das doppelt so geile Teil gibt. Dann muss ich mich entweder wieder operieren lassen, und by the way, auch das geht nicht beliebig oft. Das ist ja wie mit einem Gerät, das man dauernd öffnet, was eigentlich nicht dafür gedacht ist, geöffnet zu werden. Das wird ja nicht besser. Irgendwann ist die Nipsel ab. Und dann ist die Schraube weg. Das wird ja nicht besser, wenn man es dauernd ausmacht.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, wir sprechen dann gleich darüber, was das Problem ist, das Ding überhaupt anzuschließen, also diese Verbindung herzukriegen, zwischen Nerven und einem technischen Gerät, der nicht auf Kontakten basiert, sondern wirklich gewachsen ist. Und dann, warum das genau bei dem Operieren nicht beliebig oft funktioniert. Vorher aber sozusagen die Erweiterungen hier, die wir noch mitbekommen, zwangsweise das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Halbe Stunde haben wir noch im Chaos Radio, wo der Chaos Computer Club das Stuhl übernimmt, und wir sind noch mal im Monat. Heute sind Erdgeist, Jenny und Frank da. Hallo und willkommen zurück nochmal.
Hallo.
Und es geht heute darum, den menschlichen Körper durch Technik zu erweitern. Wir haben schon ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, was da so geht, was die Probleme sein könnten, was es heute schon für Technik gibt. Und dass vor allen Dingen Dinge, die wir ganz alltäglich benutzen, Smartphones zum Beispiel schon als eine Art Erweiterung unseres Körpers angesehen werden können. Und ich habe die erfreuliche Feststellung gemacht, dass die fleißigen Hörer während der Sendung ein sogenanntes Pad befüllt haben, wo man die ganze Sendung wirklich nachlesen kann. Also alle Punkte, die man, die in dieser Sendung schon aufgegriffen wurden, sind ernotiert. Und den genauen Link findet ihr im Wiki zur Sendung unter chaosradio.de. So, letzte halbe Stunde wollen wir nochmal füllen mit zumindest einem Problem, das wir haben, nämlich wie die Verbindung zwischen Technik und menschlichem Körper genau gemacht werden kann. Ihr könnt noch anrufen, wenn ihr wollt uns mal erklären, was ihr euch einbauen lassen würdet und wo ihr denkt, naja, das sollte man lieber vielleicht nicht machen. So, wir haben jetzt die letzte halbe Stunde damit abgeschlossen, dass es hieß, okay, das ist alles extern und operieren ist eigentlich nicht so richtig geil, weil dann gibt es irgendwie eine neue Version. Das heißt, das grundlegende Problem ist, es gibt noch keine Schnittstelle, die wirklich so gut ist, dass sie ganz genau alle Nerven abgreift. Warum nicht? Was ist da das Problem?
Na ja, es kommt drauf an, wie man das meint. Also so ein Bildschirm ist schon auch eine Mensch-Maschine-Schnittstelle, die eine immens große Bandbreite hat, nur mal als Beispiel. Jetzt könnte man sagen, okay, ich habe jetzt eine optische Verbindung zwischen dem Computer und meinem Hirn hergestellt. Die ist wirklich wahnsinnig breitbandig. Wenn ich jetzt die gleiche Verbindung über die Nerven direkt ohne den Umweg über die Optik herstellen wollte, müsste ich ja jeden dieser einzelnen Nervenbahnen irgendwie mit einem Chip verbinden. Das ist einfach mal nicht trivial und das ist auch eben sehr invasiv. Ja, also dazu muss man das Auge aufmachen und dazu muss man da drin rum basteln. Und dabei kann natürlich auch viel schiefgehen. Wir alle haben schon mal gehört von multiresistenten Keimen und so weiter. Also ich kenne Menge Leute, die im Medizingewerber arbeiten und die alle sagen, ey, nicht ins Krankenhaus, wenn du nicht musst. Und die wissen, warum sie das sagen. Und sowas freiwillig zu machen, nur um seine Funktionalität zu erweitern, sich dem Risiko auszusetzen, irgendeine Infektion zu kriegen oder irgendeine Komplikation zu kriegen, das ist schon eine echte Hürde. Zumal wenn es gute Alternativen gibt. Also wenn man tatsächlich nicht gehandicapt ist, dann kann ich mir vorstellen, so eine Erweiterung, die ich gerne hätte, ich würde gerne in anderen Frequenzbändern sehen können. Ich würde gerne im Infrarotbereich sehen können. Ich würde gerne im Terraherzbereich sehen können.
Dann müsste ich mir für dich aber noch andere Unterwäsche anziehen.
Keine Details bitte.
So genau wollten wir das nicht wissen. Aber das kann man ja erreichen, indem man eine Brille baut mit einem Bildschirm drauf, die mir sowohl das Live-Bild zeigt, als auch Bilder in anderen Spektren überlagert beispielsweise. Also Google hat gerade vorgestellt, so ein Projekt, wo sie eben eine Augmented Reality-Brille bauen wollen, anbieten wollen. Das ist ja so ein erster Schritt in die Richtung. Alle, die den großartigen Roman von Daniel Suarez, Demon und Darknet gelesen haben, die wissen auch, um welche Brille es da geht.
Unbedingt Leseempfehlung?
Unbedingt Leseempfehlung, jawohl. Da geht es ja letztlich auch in einem Body Enhancement. Was ich mir eben auch wünschen würde, wäre, wenn irgendwas in Kollisionskurs mit mir ist, dass ich eine Warnung kriege. Also wenn irgendwas, was Groß und Schnelles auf mich zukommt und mich treffen wird, wenn ich nichts unternehme.
Selbst wenn ich es noch nicht sehe. Exoskelett, die ich einfach gleich zusammenzogen lassen.
Solche Sachen gibt es ja schon. Zumindest Exo-Mente halber. Also quasi das Weiterdenken von dem Kompassgürtel, von dem Erdgasthorn erzählt hat. Was wieder mal beim Militär entwickelt wurde, nämlich zum Beispiel Westen, die man unter den Fliegeranzug zieht und die einen durch so kleine Pikse an der richtigen Stelle warnen, aus welcher Richtung gerade der Feind kommt. Also klar ist, wir haben noch eine Menge Sensoren an unserer Hautoberfläche zum Beispiel, mit denen man noch experimentieren kann, wo man sich halt einfach noch Sachen ausdenken kann. Wie wir vorhin schon erzählt haben, ist das Hirn in überraschender Weise in der Lage, Sensorimpulse bestimmt einer eigenen gewohnheitsmäßig zuzuordnen. Und dementsprechend kann man dieses mit ein bisschen Training eben auch benutzen. Also wenn man sich anguckt, wie zum Beispiel, was wir vorhin erzählt hatten, die Sache mit der Armprothese, wo man sagt, man braucht drei bis zwölf Monate Training, aber danach kann man andere Nerven benutzen für Sachen, wofür sie ursprünglich nicht vorgesehen waren. Und so ähnlich ist es eben auch mit den Nerven zum Beispiel in der Hautüberfläche, die man für solche Dinge auch benutzen kann. Und man genau diese Übersetzung von Sinnen in andere Sinne finde ich sehr spannend. Es gibt zum Beispiel auch Projekte, um für blinde Menschen die Geometrie eines Raumes in dreidimensional zu erfassen und in Akustik umzusetzen. Es gibt halt Blinde, die machen sowas selber, indem sie so Schnallzlaute machen mit der Zunge, also Klapp, Klapp, Klapp, Laute, und aus den Reflektionen im Raum sich selber ein Bild bauen. So wie Fledermäuse quasi. Genau. Und sowas gibt es dann auch in Technik, also dass man halt einfach einen 3D-Bild zum Beispiel mit sowas wie einer Kinect erfasst, von dem Raum, und das dann wiederum in Akustik umsetzt. Also dass man halt Geräusche von Gegenständen, die näher kommen oder so erzeugt. Und diese Fähigkeit des menschlichen Körpers, Sinne A, höher aufgelöst zu benutzen, und B, auch so zu benutzen, wie sie überhaupt nicht vorgesehen sind oder wie sie die Evolution bisher noch nicht gemacht hat, die ist extrem spannend. Da gibt es halt noch so viele Möglichkeiten, dass man noch eine Menge Platz hat, bevor man dann irgendwie mit dem Skype heran muss.
Genau das ist der Punkt. Solange es noch andere Optionen gibt, würde man das ja nicht machen wollen. Auch der Gürtel von Erdgeist vorhin, der ist ja auch so ein Beispiel. Man könnte den natürlich jetzt mit mehr Vibratoren ausstatten, mehrzeilig sozusagen und auch nicht nur acht, sondern sagen wir mal 32 rundum. Und dann kann man schon ein sehr subtiles Bild von Dingen, die im Weg stehen, durch entsprechende Vibrationen an diesen Stellen symbolisieren. Oder einen Weg. Ich habe einfach eine Route berechnet. Palm hat auf so etwas ein Patent, habe ich gerade gestern gesehen, bei der Recherche zur Sendung. Ein Patent darauf, dass man in einem Smart Device eine Route rechnet und genauso eine Art Aktorgürtel, Vibratorgürtel, einem jetzt den Weg entlang der Route zeigt. Das heißt, ich laufe gerade aus und irgendwann geht die Vibrationsrichtung nach rechts und dann weiß ich, ich drehe mich so lange nach rechts, bis die Vibration wieder vorne ist und fixiere damit sozusagen meinen nächsten Wegpunkt. Und somit kann man sich quasi, ohne dass man auf irgendwo rauf gucken muss, ohne dass man beim Autofahren abgelenkt wird, erfahren, an der nächsten Kreuzung muss ich rechts abbiegen, dann muss ich so und so lang geradeaus fahren und dann muss ich langsam links abbiegen oder auch zu Fuß, ohne irgendwas anzuschauen und ohne mich ablenken zu lassen. Man kann sich dabei vermutlich unterhalten, man kann dabei vermutlich beliebiger andere Dinge tun und wird trotzdem intuitiv wissen, wo man lang muss.
Und der Hack wäre dann diese Route zu hacken und jemand woanders hinzuschicken. Jetzt sind diese, also wie gesagt, ihr wollt es lieber nicht invasiv, das sind aber alles sehr praktisch pragmatische Überlegungen, um nochmal auf diese Wünsch dir was Sache zurückzukommen. Ich würde sagen, das Ende der Fahnschlange wäre der Cyborg-Körper mit einem Gehirn drin.
Am besten mit meinem Gehirn drin, ja.
Die Vision dahinter ist ja das Brain-Computer-Interface. Also das BCI, da gibt es Ansätze, ich hab so was auch schon mal ausprobiert, da wird halt ein EEG genommen, jetzt noch mit Kontakten auf der Kopfoberfläche. Die Idee dahinter ist, dass Aktivität im Hirn sozusagen Potentialdifferenzen erzeugt, die sich bis auf die Kopfoberfläche fortpflanzen und man die mit EEG-Sensorik, also hoch empfindlicher elektromagnetischer Sensorik, abgreifen kann. Und darüber eben bestimmte Muster feststellen kann, die erzeugt werden, wenn man beispielsweise die Hand bewegt. Ich hab das seinerzeit, das ist schon ewig her, das muss heute schon viel, viel besser sein, ausprobiert. Da musste man eben, was weiß ich, ein paar tausend Mal eine Maus bewegen. Und das System hat dabei gelernt, wie mein Hirnstrommuster aussieht, während ich diese Maus bewege. Und irgendwann konnte man die Maus weglegen und nur noch denken, dass man diese Maus bewegt. Und dieser Maus-Cursor bewegte sich dann also in diese Richtung. Das war nicht perfekt, das war noch sehr holprig, aber das ist auch schon zehn Jahre her. Also das muss heute schon sehr viel besser gehen. Das ist natürlich eine Form von Brain-Computer-Interface, die sich, wenn man nicht die Schädeldecke dazwischen hat, sehr, sehr, sehr viel besser ginge. Wenn man also tatsächlich jetzt Elektronen an bestimmte Stellen im Hirn implantiert und diese Informationen dann über eine Schnittstelle nach draußen gibt, kann man sehr, sehr, sehr viel präziser ermitteln, was der Mensch da gerade denkt. Das geht ja so weit, dass man heute über Sampling von immens vielen Bildern, also man zeigt Leuten Bilder und nimmt dabei ein Kernspintomogramm ihrer Gehirnaktivität auf. Und wenn man das ein paar Tausend Mal gemacht hat, können die Leute an andere Bilder denken, an beliebige andere Bilder oder auch zum Beispiel was träumen. Und der Computer errechnet, wie ungefähr dieses Bild so grob aussieht, dass man gerade denkt, aufgrund der Beispiele, die man vorher gegeben hat, indem man Bilder angeschaut hat.
Und geht es dann sozusagen auch umgedreht, also so wie in Strange Days, dass man quasi im Hirn Bilder erzeugt und so den Leuten Filme zeigt, ohne dass man...
Naja, also wie gesagt, das nächste, wo man da momentan dran ist, ist halt diese transkranierende Magnetstimulation. Aber da sind... Da ist die Technik noch nicht so weit, dass man da richtig ins Hirn reinrennen kann.
Man müsste da hochpräzise an bestimmte Stellen explizit ganz genaue Impulse geben. Ich glaube, die Richtung rein ist sehr viel schwieriger über eine Elektronik als raus. Also rein, da eignen sich eher die Sensoren, die man eh schon hat, die auch breitbandig angebunden sind, wie Tastsinne auf Zunge, Finger, wie Gehör, wie Optik eben und so weiter. Aber raus, ich glaube, da wäre es schon sinnvoll, sich direkt an die Nerven anzudocken.
Und gibt es nicht, wenn diese ganzen Enhancements, von denen wir jetzt die ganze Zeit geredet haben, wenn die kommen, gibt es dann nicht auch die Gefahr, dass wir eine Zweiklassengesellschaft kriegen? Weil heutzutage, also Smartphones und Internetzugang sind tatsächlich in einen Bereich angekommen, wo es zumindest theoretisch denkbar ist, das hat jeder, zumindest hier in Deutschland. Aber so Enhancements, die dann hochtechnisch sind?
Das hat nicht jeder, also auch Smartphones sind jetzt schon nicht bei jedem verfügbar. Es gibt irgendwie auch gerade auch Zweiklassengesellschaft bei den älteren Menschen, die damit den Smartphones gar nicht klarkommen. Aber was ich vorhin ja extra gefragt hatte, war, ob die Krankenkasse diese Implantate oder diese Prothesen übernimmt. Ist halt die Frage, ob irgendwann, wenn bestimmte Körperteile einfach wegen Altersschwäche ausfallen würden, ob man dann überhaupt noch eines natürlichen Todes sterben würde oder ob die Gesellschaft dann dafür aufkommen muss, dass älteren Menschen dann nacheinander alle ausfallenden Organe ersetzt werden. Und wie es dann aussieht, wer es bezahlen soll, ob man da im Vorfeld eine spezielle Versicherung dazu kaufen muss und ob man dazu besonders reich sein muss, damit Leber, Milz, Lunge, keine Ahnung, was wichtig ist, Alter ersetzt wird.
Also die am meisten verwendete Prothese sind der Zahnimplantate. Und die werden von der Krankenkasse ja schon nicht mehr vollständig gedeckt. Also wenn man tatsächlich den State of the Art haben will, das heißt also halt irgendwie eine poröse Titanschraube in den Kiefer, auf der dann oben halt irgendwie ein custom gebasteltes Keramikimplantat drauf sitzt, ist nichts, was die Krankenkasse halt vollständig bezahlt, sondern da muss man halt selber ran. Das heißt, wir haben also diese, diese Zwei-Klassen-Gesellschaft bildet sich da sowieso schon langsam heraus, eben an den Stellen, wo es am meisten kostet oder eben zu teuer ist und vor allen Dingen in hohen Zahlen auftritt. Also zum Beispiel so eine Beinprothese oder eine Armprothese, die wird halt sehr viel seltener verwendet als eben zum Beispiel so ein Zahnimplantat, was halt millionenfach implantiert wird. Und dementsprechend verschieben sich dann natürlich einfach klar die Dinge dahin, dass also Menschen, die mehr Geld haben, im Zweifel halt die bessere Technologie bekommen. Und in dem Augenblick, wo es halt dahin geht, dass die Implantate eben nicht mehr medizinisch notwendig, also im Sinne einer Restoration von ohnehin vorhandenen Fähigkeiten sind, sondern ja mehr oder minder optionaler Luxus werden, da wird es wahrscheinlich dann eben noch eine Mehrklassengesellschaft geben, also die halt auch dahin geht zum Beispiel, ob man bestimmte Jobs ohne bestimmte Implantate schlicht nicht bekommen kann, weil man sie halt nicht ausfüllen kann, weil man nicht den Anforderungen entspricht oder bestimmte Schnittstellen schlicht nicht hat, die halt zum Beispiel für die Bedienung von komplexen Maschinen notwendig sind.
Das wird mit Sicherheit wieder beim Militär anfangen, die ja auch am intensivsten schon sozusagen im Live-System Brain Computer Interfaces und eben andere Body Enhancements nutzt. Also mitunter ist in diesen Jets schon das Auswählen von Zielen beziehungsweise das Auslösen des Abschusses über ein Brain Computer Interface gelöst, einfach um die Reaktionszeit zu verkürzen in dem Moment. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass in kurzer Zeit, also in einer Größenordnung einstellige Jahreszahlen, es notwendig werden könnte, wenn nicht sowieso alles in Richtung, komplett in Richtung Drohnen geht, aber dann betrifft es halt den Drohnenoperator, dass er eine Schnittstelle sich implantieren lassen muss, wenn er diesen Job machen will, damit er schnell genug reagieren kann, schnell genug die Entscheidungen auch in einer Handlung übersetzen kann, ohne darüber über irgendeine Motorik gehen zu müssen.
Wenn man das weiterdenkt, dann kommst du bei der Straßenverkehrsordnung raus, dass du am Ende vielleicht dein eigenes Auto nur noch steuern darfst, wenn du solche Interfaces in deinem Gehirn implementiert hast.
Denke mal, dass der, also realistisch betrachtet, wird es nicht an solchen Stellen sein, weil, also wie gesagt bei Flugzeugen werden es halt die Drohnen, die werden ohnehin autonomer und Autos fahren sowieso schon von selber. Also, dass der Mensch da zwingend notwendig ist, ist halt irgendwie ja nicht bewiesen und belegt im Gegenteil.
Tolle Autos, blöderweise sitzen da Menschen drin, ja.
Ja, die sind halt eigentlich nur dafür da, irgendwie Menschen durch die Gegend zu fahren.
Das ist ja auch ein cooles Body Enhancement. Ja, ein Exoskelett, erster Güte. Das ist sogar...
Vier-Räderiges Exoskelett, total super.
Der weiß ja sogar, wie weit was weg ist und so, ist ja super.
Ja, meins ist zweiräderig.
Markus Exoskelett liegt ja besonders eng an, wenn wir alle drin sitzen.
Weil ihr so gut genährt seid. Okay, anderes Thema. Ich würde gerne am Ende von euch noch mal wissen, wie ihr, wenn ihr in die Glaskugel guckt, so die nächsten Jahre seht. Und jetzt also unabhängig von den Problemen, die es damit gibt, die wir gerade beschrieben haben, was die Entwicklungen sind, auf die ihr euch freut. Wo ihr aber auch denkt, die sind tatsächlich auch realisierbar.
Ich fand ja die Quadrocopter-Entwicklung total toll, weil ich so ein bisschen gedacht hab, man könne sich irgendwann reinsetzen und damit dann ziemlich präzise durch die Gegend fahren. Aber es gibt andere ähnliche Entwicklungen. Es gibt da den Schweizer Piloten, der sich da so ein Jetpack auf dem Rücken draufgesetzt hat, aus seinem Flugzeug rausspringt und dann mit so kleinen Stummelflügeln hinten dran, da einfach ganz natürlich damit durch die Gegend fliegt und dann noch mit Falschum landet. Aber wenn sowas irgendwann mal, man geht aus der Tür raus und kann so senkrecht starten, fliegt der hin, wo man hin möchte.
Also du willst doch eigentlich nur deinen Flying Car haben, oder?
Nee, warum Car? Car ist irgendwie auch so eine Krücke. Eigentlich will ich ganz nah dran. Vogelflug ist natürlich der uralte Traum, aber...
Ich will so ein Exoskelett mit zwei großen Flügeln dran. Und dann schwingst du die Schwingen und hebst dich halt in die Lüfte und spürst dann die Thermik im kleinen Finger.
Und es muss blau sein.
Nein, ganz realistisch denke ich, wir werden eine Menge sehen in dem Bereich Augmented Reality. Also Dinge, die ich in mein live visuelles Bild eingeblendet bekomme. Also eine Brille, die mir Informationen einblendet, während ich durchgucke oder eben Smartphones, die ich irgendwo hinhalte in Richtung eines Gebäudes auf dem Fenster und dann sagt er mir, was dahinter ist oder in welche Richtung ich gehen muss, wenn ich da und da hin will. Wir werden mehr solche Dinge sehen, wie der Gürtel, den Erdgeist beschrieben hat, in manchfaltiger Form. Das ist ja nicht der einzige Weg, so was zu machen über Vibrationsmotörchen. Da gibt es ja Tausende Wege, elektrisch stimulieren, etc. thermisch stimulieren. Aber ich glaube, die meisten dieser Aspekte werden erst mal extern bleiben. Sicherlich, und da hoffe ich, dass es soweit ist, bis wir 20, 30 Jahre älter sind, das Exoskelett für die älteren Leute. Also mit einem Rollator zu all die Schieben. Ich glaube, das wär nicht mein Traum. Ich würde dann schon gerne so ein Ding haben, dass mich da halt agil hinläuft.
Und wie vielstens drei Meter hoch ist und irgendwie fünfmal so stark, wie du heute bist.
Nee, ich mein, aber das ist genau der Punkt. In dem Moment, wo so Body Enhancements, also eigentlich Prothesen, besser sind als das Original. In dem Moment wollen das normale Menschen auch. Also wenn Blinde jetzt eine Technologie kriegen, mit der sie nicht nur sich perfekt orientieren können, sondern auch noch sehen, was hinter ihnen ist und auch noch sehen, wenn da Autos um die Ecke kommen, die sie noch gar nicht zu sehen sind, spätestens dann finden andere Leute, das hätten sie auch ganz gerne. Ja, also ist immer die Frage. Hörgeräte, das hatten wir vorhin schon. Wenn jemand, der schwerhörig ist, plötzlich mehr Möglichkeiten hat als jemand, der normal hört. Oder jemand, der Brillenträger ist, plötzlich deutlich besser sehen kann als jemand, der normalsichtig ist. In dem Moment überlegt sich der Normalsichtig, denn dem brauch ich jetzt nicht auch eine Brille.
Das ist heute mit Augengläsern ja schon, dass du nicht über 120 Prozent nach Lasik da so an Sehkraft rausbekommst.
Weil es eben aber auch wieder degeneriert. Und dann am Ende doch wieder bei 100 Prozent oder weniger.
Ja, aber ist ja wurscht. Ich meine, letztlich, was momentan noch fehlt, ist eine Brille, die sich automatisch in ihrer Brennweite an die Brennweite meines Auges adaptiert. Die einfach ein bisschen stärker das tut, was mein Auge versucht zu tun, aber nicht mehr so recht kann. Und mir dann eben die Brille lernt, dass ich jetzt hier makro will. Ich gucke ganz dicht irgendwo ran, und das heißt, sie funktioniert jetzt wie eine Lupe. Und fokussiert ganz stark auf diesen Bereich. Und wenn ich in die Entfernung gucke, naja, dann stellt sie halt auf Entfernung scharf. Das gibt einen größeren Range. Das werden wir sehen in den nächsten 10, 15, 10 Jahren. Doch in 10 gibt es das. In 10 Jahren werden Leute, die es schlechter sehen, als wir heute besser sehen, als die, die heute gut sehen.
Frank, hast du auch noch einen speziellen Wunsch?
Naja, also ich denke, dass die Entwicklung natürlich da hingehen wird, den menschlichen Körper zumindest zu erhalten und so moderat aufzubessern. Aber ich hätte tatsächlich gerne Augmented Reality Erweiterungen schon sehr gern. Also Dinge, mit denen man halt einfach seine Umgebung besser wahrnehmen kann, sich besser erinnern kann, sich im Zweifel besser orientieren kann. Und die sind ja auch relativ nahe dran. Und ansonsten hätte ich gerne einfach ein 3 Meter hohes Exoskelett.
Mit Laserkanonen?
Ja, mit Laserkanonen und Raketenwerfern.
Zu viel Avatar geguckt.
Nee, um zu Aldi zu gehen.
Da passt du nicht durch die Tür.
Dann schon.
Diese Entwicklung der Exoskelette, es gibt ja auch so, Justarte Frank mir neulich erst erzählt, so Exoskelette, die schon noch eher ein gewebtes Material sind, die kontrahieren können, die man sich nicht mehr spossen kann.
Genau, es ist so eine Entwicklung, das ist auch so ein DAPA Projekt. Was sie tun, ist so eine Art dicken Taucheranzug bauen. Das ist halt so ein neoprenatiges Material, in dem künstliche Muskelfasern drin sind, die elektrisch betrieben werden. Und Sensorik dazu, sodass man, wenn man sich stößt, also wenn sozusagen das Material merkt, man hat einen Impact an irgendeiner Stelle, dann wird es halt hart an dieser Stelle. Und Schritt zwei ist, dass man sich, dass dieses Ding einen bewegen kann. Also dass es halt eine quasi überall verteilte, dünne zusätzliche Muskelschicht gibt, die aber stärker ist als der Mensch darunter. Und man eben nicht mehr das Problem hat, dass man so ein Exoskelett irgendwo festschnallen muss oder sich da dransetzen, reinsetzen muss und irgendwie dann die üblichen Probleme mit Druck stellen und irgendwie sowas hat, sondern das halt einfach eine quasi sozusagen eine zweite Haut ist, die einen bewegen kann. Also da gibt es noch eine Menge mehr Ansätze als so, sag mal, so Mechwarrior-Style.
Das ist mir persönlich auch sympatisch, also eine kleine Jacke, die mich noch ein bisschen stärker macht.
Muss man nur aufpassen, wenn diese Jacke dann irgendwann unkontrolliert anfängt zu kontrahieren, dann kannst du dir wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich schnell den Arm brechen. Da ist dann Softwarequalität schon echt toll.
Gut, hoffen wir mal, dass sie sozusagen von einer firten Firma geschrieben wird. Ich möchte jetzt ganz zum Schluss, weil das Chaos Radio ist gleich zu Ende, noch eine Frage erstellen. Und zwar habt ihr von diesem Gürtel jetzt mehrfach erzählt, der einem die Richtung angibt. Und ihr habt auch erzählt, dass er eigentlich seit anderthalb Jahren verpeilt, das Ding mal zu bauen. Wie schwierig ist das denn?
Gar nicht. Gar nicht schwierig. Man muss es jetzt nur endlich mal wieder machen.
Es gab doch halt am Ende nur so ein Detailproblem, dass der Kompassstein, den ich mir abkommen lassen, mit dem Mikrocontroller nicht sprechen wollte.
Ich kann es kurz erläutern, wie man so was machen würde. Es gibt Motorcontroller für diese Vibrationsmotoren. Das Problem ist, entweder macht man sie nur an und aus. Das ist aber nicht cool. Man will auch ein bestimmtes Vibrationsmuster erzeugen. Dafür braucht man eine H-Brücke, also eine Schaltung, mit der man den Motor vorwärts als auch rückwärts drehen lassen kann. Wobei die Richtung nicht so wichtig ist. Viel wichtiger ist, dass wenn man ihn jetzt mit Kraft angemacht hat, man ihn auch mit Kraft wieder bremsen kann, damit man einen gezielten Impuls, einen Vibrationsimpuls erzeugen kann. Und das auch in einer bestimmten Frequenz, sodass man über die Änderung der Vibrationsfrequenz und über die Vibrationsstärke noch mal unterschiedliche Aussage machen kann. Und die will man jetzt ansteuern über einen Mikrocontroller, beispielsweise einen Arduino. Also ein Arduino, das ist eigentlich so ein Elektronik-Open-Source-Projekt, eigentlich eine C-Library für Atmel Mikrocontroller.
Also Leute, die Ahnung haben, wissen jetzt schon, wovon du redest und denken sich wahrscheinlich, okay, das kann noch nicht so schwer sein.
Das ist nicht schwer.
Gibt es denn irgendwo einen Link, den man klicken kann? Gibt es eine Bauanleitung für das Ding quasi?
Es gibt eine. Jetzt hab ich den Link vergessen.
So, Hausaufgabe für die anwesenden Leute im Chaosradio ist. Bitte den Link von den Gürteln noch mal raussuchen. Es gibt ein Pad zur Sendung, wo die Hörer ganz fleißig alles zusammengetragen haben, was hier in dieser Sendung gesagt wurde. Link dazu auf Chaosradio.de. So, Famous Last Words. Will die einer noch sagen oder sind wir eigentlich durch?
I want my flying car.
Auch am Ende des Menschen, Maschinen, Maschinen, Menschen, Chaosradios, ist das der große Wunsch. Erdgeist Steini und Frank vom Chaos Computer Club Warnier haben erzählt, wie das so gehen kann mit der Menschenmaschine und den Maschinenmenschen. Vielen Dank dafür.
Gerne.
Es gibt in circa einer Stunde oder zwei vielleicht auf Fritz.de den Podcast zur Sendung. Dann könnt ihr euch die ganze Sendung nochmal nachhören. Dann auch demnächst auf Chaosradio.de. Hier gibt es jetzt auch gleich einen Track von Trekkie Birthday, der Website heißt und die wir immer spielen. Nach mir kommt Henrik Schröder und bewirft euch mit Punkmusik in eure akustischen Extremitäten. Und mir bleibt dann eigentlich nur noch eins zu sagen. Und das ist, mein Name ist Marcs Richter. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.